good morning everybody um nice to see
people online so
uh welcome to our symposium on
differentiable julia
uh my name is chris hill i'm going to
moderate the first hour and our first
speaker this morning is ludovic russ
going to talk about
gpu accelerated optimization uh using
julia ad capabilities for scalable
inverse modeling okay
off you go
yep
okay well thank you for the introduction
chris and well welcome everyone
um thanks a lot for inviting me to to
talk a bit about um
work on uh g2 accelerated optimization
and well in particular
about recent work i was doing with my
collaborator ivan hudkin here at eth uh
and we got really excited about um using
basically julia's aed capabilities uh
for
like performing or trying to perform
scalable inverse modeling and i
don't have much time but i'll try to do
my best to
share some of the um recent excitement
we with you uh since we got things
working like a couple of minutes ago
so yeah
a maybe a very short intro about earth
so well uh what is earth system modeling
so basically we have some earth and it's
composed of different um let's say
subsystems such as atmosphere and ice
the land part oceans and well certainly
many more i don't want to
be short on that side but
let's keep that global picture and while
this little system they work this
subsystem basically they interact
together
and
uh well that's kind of an interest it's
particularly those days because while
we're obviously
everyone certainly feels it now in
summer that climate is warming it's
warming uh
you know more than uh expected way uh
some extremes here and there etc so
basically the system gets perturbed and
well suddenly it gets that's an
interesting to to be and important to be
able to to predict and understand how
this subsystem like interact and work
together
um and well
we are
in placeology like doing research you
know glycology group so we have
particular interest at least for now on
well the evolution of ice sheets and
glaciers and how these ice sheets and
glacier behave in that
ice subsystem and how they kind of
integrate as a whole in the earth system
and
so one of the obvious um
observations on ice and glacier uh with
kind of regarding a climate deregulation
that we're
experiencing right now is that
basically glacier flow accelerates
glacier and ice sheet melt faster than
expected and here like the color maps
you see are glacial velocities and so
well basically
one of the interesting the one of the
interesting topic is to understand how
ice muscles are lost and to trade
because this has potential uh impact for
well sea level rise hydropower sensory
transport and much more but ultimately
well i guess the most thing is and the
big picture is like threat and risk for
one human human being
so well the idea is that well we do all
this in a modeling framework so
we cannot and don't want to wait on uh
observation to happen we want to predict
it before it happens basically so
for latin we have like the models and
while models we uh want to make like
prediction here is an example of uh how
for example a volume on alpine glacier
would evolve uh under assumption of
different or various climate scenarios
and we see that it's quite quite a big
variability but
that's also where we need the modeling
exercise for
and well ideally we want to
be able to constrain our model with past
observation in order to make more
accurate
future predictions
so for that exercise we want to use
inverse modeling and ideally scalable
inverse modeling so on one hand we have
measurements devices like for iso
velocities for example satellites and on
the other hand in our computer we have a
physical description of like
how
we can model the evolution or the like
the
ice velocity ice flow velocity
then
the field we have field measurements
like we can go and measure
eye thicknesses we can go and measure
using a gps like um
um high speed and in a computer
simulation well we have to resolve our
equation and we want to have like a
solution for the ice ice flow uh
patterns
velocities etc
and and now what we can do in our in
inverse strategies is we can um try to
define like uh well we kind of can
constrain our computer simulation with
measurements so in that case we have
like observed ice thicknesses for
example our ice velocities and
find our computer simulation using uh
the observation and
using like the
the way we do it it's like we can define
a conclusion that somehow measures how
far the uh results produce with our uh
model are
[Music]
away or what's discrepancy with respect
to the observation and then we can
basically improve or refine or modify
some of the parameters of our model in
order to better fit the observation it's
really valuable because well that's a
way to somehow optimize or tune our
models and we can tune on data and then
we'll make
ideally better predictions
well guess what this operation may
become a costly cycle especially if one
has a heavy forward models or
multiphysics 3d solution and so on
many components nonlinear and
and in our well inversion or um like
optimization strategy we we're gonna
have to call or repeat this um costly
cycle quite a lot of time so we better
uh
like make sure that we we use something
optimized there
and optimized nowadays in terms of
computing well guess what i'm going to
talk about gpu computing so well a
couple of weeks ago like first exit
scale machine frontiers uh powered by
amd gpus was just uh came just announced
that uh oak ridge um while other
machines for example in switzerland we
have nvidia powered machine but
basically
most of the recent and top
10 and more super computers they run on
use because while gpu go fa go fast
why gpu go fast it's because where we're
limited by the memory transfers
and gpu actually uh gpus manage to uh do
a much better job in transferring memory
like numbers from memory to compute you
need to make the computations and
discounts
at least the 10x uh higher um throughput
so yeah well now
okay makes sense running gpus but then
why julia and gpus well
julia had
solves the two language problem that we
have a unique language or a single
language for prototyping and development
and
really managed to get us to the hardware
p performance so for example using
some
julia packages we developed we can
really solve like your non-linear
diffusion equation at about like just
seven percent of peak memory throughput
but actually solving what non-linear
diffusion equation for example
and well we can scale this up so go off
one two well here we test it up to
2997 gpus and only losing like kind of
1.5 percent of parallel efficiency so
basically we are not at all penalized
from running on 2000 gpus with respect
of running on one
yeah so now getting a bit more into but
what's
our inversion strategy and for this we
use the joint method the giant method is
very powerful because while we
well we combine the joint method with
the gradient descent here and so per
kind of inversion step we need uh one
non-linear uh forward problem solved one
linear a joint problem solve and then a
point wise gradient evaluation and then
we can use well um
gradient descent in order to optimize
the parameter here for example an alpha
and uh given uh the gradient so the
derivative of the cos function with
respect to the parameter we want to
optimize
the cool thing is that while this
approach is independent of the number of
dimensions this computation
may be sensitive to local minimum though
but well let's keep this for a while
uh the way the cool thing is that uh
part of the building blocks we need to
make this a joint method to work we can
get it with
situation and that's actually the topic
of the rest of the talk
um yeah so the cool thing in julia is
there are tools for making ad and that
works on the gpu so the gpu stack could
have the jl and gpu.gl this is already
pretty now mature and
better
uh then there's a cool tool that's
called enzyme and that that permits to
make um automatic differentiation on
llvm level and this kind of works on gpu
and achieves pretty high efficiency
and ideally in the future we want to
combine those and like use it also in
the packages we develop which is uh for
extensive and inclusive global grid but
that's still working progress
so a
joint method what we have we have a
forward problem and then we can
integrate this forward problem in sort
of time in order to solve it so want a
solution of x
now we can define on a joint problem a
transposed air equal s and there we can
use the same approach so we can
integrate
the steady state equation inside of time
and try to solve for air
and
same so we kind of gradient of the cause
function this djd alpha
which is defined as such now the cool
thing is that this block in red this
actually like
those are matrix vector products and
these we can get automatically generated
by enzyme using automatic
differentiation
and well the the solution
we use here is uh the so-called sort of
transient method uh we just get a paper
accepted today on the solution method
and the coolest thing is that both the
forward and the joint problem they
basically
work with the same iterative parameters
so it makes the thing pretty much
robust
regarding the
code implementation so here for solving
a 1d non-linear diffusion equation
making the inversion with ad on the gpu
well the only thing we need are well a
residual function here the residual of
the non-linear diffusion equation
cuda kernel
and the forward
is calling this kernel repeat repeatedly
uh and uh making some um
damned
uh evaluation and updates for kind of
better convergence like this if your
curious is explained in the paper i
advertised just before cool thing is for
the adjoint we have strategy we just
need now to wrap the enzyme auto diff in
a in a function such that we call like
in a kernel
but that some
saying we have this duplicated variable
and then well the gradient the cost
function gradient
also just uh called to enzyme uh passing
the appropriate uh temporary variable
for the matrix vector product at the
right places
so well then kind of i had to
unfortunately skip quite some things
because we don't have i don't have much
time to share all my excitement about
this but
we managed to get
some 2d
shallow eyes
to work
and inversion for
mass balance gradients so that's data
from the paper by additional
and they here use a like hand tuned
naive inversion strategy that serves
their need and we kind of try to see if
we can retrieve the same uh using
basically ad on the gpu now and without
having to do like too much manual
derivation or tuning
and so that's what we get so we here
have um initial um
h so height of ice eye thickness
distribution over a
synthetic topography and we our cost
function is where we try to
age observation uh our like modeled eye
sickness with eye sickness observation
and well run the inversion to optimize
the mass balance gradient parameter and
well that's what we get so the
sand here shows the evolution of the uh
well misfit of the cos function with
respect of gradient decent iteration so
i'll drop about two orders of magnitude
of the
misfit and
over 20 great and decent iteration and
this gives us a pretty good fit with
observation and so this code was
basically an extension in 2d to this
short small code snippet in 1d i showed
you and this well both the joint
residual and the cost function gradient
where obtained automatically using
enzyme and this runs this runs on the
a100 and video gpu
like 15 minutes ago that's why i was a
bit
late
so
we're coming up
there are many things to say that maybe
regarding performance as that's kind of
why the whole motivation why to do this
on gpu so if we look at the effective
memory throughput so like how
efficiently we can use the gpu we saw
that
assuming we have a uh optimal forward
problem that runs about one-fourth
one-fifth of the
throughput while solving a real-world
problem the joint is totally on par so
well
enzyme is really efficient to manage to
code us as efficient as our hand-coded
forward model
and while this results in very short
time per iteration that well one could
analyze the slope but it kind of behaves
as expected
with respect to four problems um on the
rs on the other hand while the joints
are being leaner it requires much less
iteration in our iterative framework
because
compared to the forward problem which is
non-linear so that's also a nice nice
thing to have
and well not just
well out of nowhere like comparison
between cpu and gpu
well indeed we just checked that when
our gpu
framework
runs faster uh there would be like long
discussion and and and different ways to
to show this in a very in a more uh kind
of robust way but basically we're like
at least sort of magnitude faster on the
gpu and it scales much better
so well with this i hope i could share
some of our current enjoyment and i want
to thank evan who helped out quite a lot
on that as well
fantastic thank you very much
so there's at least one question in the
pigeonhole thing so i'm just going to
show that
i don't know whether you
want to comment on that so it's can you
talk about how easy or difficult it was
to use enzyme to differentiate your code
well um
the the the the use of enzyme itself was
let's say pretty
easy because it's really concise and
there's no well the big machinery i
guess is under the hood so they explode
when the really nice functions are
exposed
that does everything
true like we we struggle a bit to to
kind of uh guess some of the missing
docs so what i guess documentation
enhancement would definitely be very
well very well welcome
but
well
we didn't keep that much issue so uh
there is one thing that's currently
fixed is basically the support for
trigonometric function like sine cosine
power exponent logarithms on the gpu
because there are needed a tweak on gpu
compiler to not optimize before the id
passes are done but optimize afterwards
that was just get merged into master so
i guess with that fix
will pretty ready to go for
uh most of the things that could happen
in
in the mat world
fantastic okay so the other question i
think maybe you could type some things
into pigeonhole uh ludovic which is
about just
how parallel stencil and differential
equations might
join up one day in some
happy union okay um
so
um but in the interest of time i think
we have boris krauts up next boris i'm
going to add your slides to the stream
and you to the video and i'm going to
let i'm going to remove you okay
yeah sure
thanks lotto
okay here's boris and here are some
slides so boris is in mints in germany
he told me and um he does solid earth
work so he's been working with julia for
a year or so now and is
interested in uh both
just forward modelling and uh adjoint
modeling i think though boris do you
want to take it away
yeah so thank you very much for inviting
me to this so as you will see the
equations that we are solving are very
similar to those are actually identical
to those in the
for glaciers but quite different from
the earth and the atmosphere so the
earth is dynamic
not just on the time scale in the
atmosphere of a few minutes but also on
the time scale of millions of years and
that's what we are mostly interested in
and we're doing this kind of simulations
where we try to understand what happens
if tectonic plates plates collides and
how they form mountain belts
we try to understand how this
is compatible or not compatible with
information given in the geological
records and we try to figure out which
of the model parameters matter most so
this is something that we're doing
forward modeling and a typical example
of such a forward simulation which is
shown
here
where you see two tectonic plates
colliding we have a zone subducting into
the earth and you see that uh
the behavior of this model is quite
complex but this is a case where we
model about 60 million years and about
one a day of computational time on 128
course
so this is this is one example of things
we are working on the other example is
has to do with how the earth behaves
today and how we can combine that with
actual observations and for example in
the in the european alps we have a lot
of geophysical data that give us an
information about how the seismic wave
speed adapts changes
we also have information measurements at
the earth's surface from gps
measurements or satellite measurements
that tell us how it deforms at the
earth's surface but what we don't
understand is how the dynamics of the
adidas sphere and these tectonic plates
are and how we can come up with a
physically consistent model that
explains all of that a similar question
is here in the puna system that is in
south america which we believe is the
largest partially molten zone and the
crust in the earth which has uh tons of
volcanoes on top of it and we try to
understand okay how much magma is
actually sitting there and how does it
feed the volcanoes on top
and this is actually an inverse modeling
question because you want to link models
with actual observations the same
computational frameworks are also rather
than complete completely different
scales for example you can simulate how
water flows to porous rocks on a
length scale of a few millimeters or you
could simulate how landslides happen at
volcanoes here so what are these
equations these are the equations of the
conservation of mass momentum and energy
as you will notice perhaps for the ones
of you coming from the atmosphere of
oceanography the conservation of
momentum equations look a little bit
different we have no inertial terms and
we have no turbulent terms because those
don't play a role over the long
time skills we are talking about
so mathematically um the computational
tricky parts looks very much like in
nearly incompressible stokes flow
equations and as you can see here
there are no time derivatives in these
equations and much of the complexity
comes because we have variations in the
viscosity of rocks or the effective
viscosity of rocks which can vary orders
of magnitudes between for example magma
moving through rocks compared to solid
rock setting next to it
uh so much of the ongoing research in
our field deals with adding more physics
to these equations for example to more
realistically describe how magma moves
through the rocks or how the rocks break
and much of the complexities actually
come from the non-linear rheology of
rocks
which is viscoelastic plastic since we
have no time derivatives in these
equations classically we have sort of
this mostly using implicit solvers using
finite element of finite different
discretizations you end up with a big
sparse matrix system which you can solve
with a direct solve for
iterative multi-grid solvers
more recently lurvik and and others have
shown that you can also use this pseudo
transients all of us to solve the same
type of equations and that is nice
because it scales much better on gpa
gpus so
the reality of rocks is complicated
because if you have rocks that are very
hot they creep like a viscous fluids
like honey but with a nonlinear
viscosity that depends on the
temperature pressure composition etc on
very
various factors that are actually not so
well known for the earth
on a much smaller time scales rocks
behave elastically
and if you have very high stresses rocks
fail in a plastic manner and and break
so the easiest way the most consistent
way with lab experiments is that rocks
are non-near maxwell viscoelastic
plastic bodies and
and that can give quite strong
nonlinearities and we're actually
working on a julia package that combines
all these point wise computations into
one package called geoprograms.gl
i will probably talk more about the
that's in the juliacon conference next
year
okay so we have been developing open
source software packages to solve the
governing equations for this for the
last two decades or so and
our 3d scalable parallel package is
called la mam that's all of these
equations and it's basically based on
the 3d stack i find the difference smart
grand cell approach
it is written in c it uses patsy and it
scales it has multi-grade condition
preconditioners and scales from 1 to
over 450 000 processors typically we use
64 to 128 cores and we also have a
binary build of version available since
a few
months so
the disadvantage of this code is that
because it is written in c it is a
significant effort to develop it has
been a significant
efforts with multiple people and usually
it's actually
very difficult for phd students to get
into this very big codes and add new
physics during the time of their phd and
this is really one of the big downsides
of having this very complicated
3d
codes and and i think julia can really
help to simplify this so i'll show you a
few examples of that uh later
so let's back let's go back to the
gradients whether we use the gradients
we have basically two applications one
is to solve the nonlinearities itself
yeah so typically our system of
equations uh is non-linear
so if you want to solve these
non-linearities you can use newton
iterations and for that you need to
define a jacobian which is basically the
derivative of the residual with respect
to your solution variables you here
and computing this jacobian for simple
problems for linear
or for just power loriologies is easy
and can be done analytically but if you
start to have this coupled physical
elasto physical plastic rheologist it
can become quite hairy to do that
and moreover if you add some rheology to
that you would have to redo the whole
job again and this is why automatic
differentiation is potentially very
powerful tool to do so and we started
looking about a year ago and to whether
it's possible to actually do a whole
framework
from julia
and using automatic differentiation for
that and um
worked a bit with jeremy coston uh on
upgrading the patsy.jl package
which is basically the julia interface
to patsy jeremy managed to do a binary
builder version of patsy which is really
cool so it works in windows mac and
linux this is one of the big
problems that most of the students i
work with have had installing patsy and
to start with so with binary builder
that is much easier now and
jeremy also created wrappers to the full
patty package but we are still working
on making
most of that more julia franti so if you
want to see some of that you can look at
this sub branch just to give you um a
proof of concept uh this is one code
that is in the branch that you see here
and that basically solves the what we
call the porosity wave equation so it's
two copper system of nonlinear equations
for the melt content and the magma
content and the effective pressure uh
that basically describes how magma may
move uh or rise up in the earth
and the way you end up quoting this is
that you have to write a local residual
routine in julia and the actual relevant
part is shown here
basically just type down these equations
and define a different scheme and
compute a local residual and if you want
to do the same thing in 2d or on 3d you
just add a few additional derivatives so
this code is just to residue full
residual codes for 1d 2d and 3d case now
the cool thing is that you can use
automatic differentiation using the
forwardif package
to then generate a jacobian from this
nonlinear system and that is done
automatically
if you can provide the sparsity pattern
that's works much faster and once you
have that you can just call patsy solve
and that's all of the nonlinear system
of equations and you can even run that
in parallel and this is the case where
it runs on four processors and you see
you get a nice quadratic uh convergence
of the nonlinear steps and this is an
illustration of how this moves where you
see two waves of magma where the bigger
one starts to overtake the smaller one
and so this is one example of automatic
differentiation that really simplifies
your life because if you have a
different set of equations here you only
have to update the residual routine and
the rest is done really automatically so
ongoing work is looking into doing the
same and trying to simulate the breaking
of rock
using so-called mode one or more two
plasticity with the physical elastic
viscoplasticity so this is shown that
this actually works as well in the real
world
so let's get back to the other part of
the gradients that has to do with the
adjoint and i think ludovic already gave
a nice introduction on how if we want to
fetch models to observations we need to
compute a misfit function and we need to
change some of the model parameters to
better adapt the models to the
observations and you can use some
gradient based approach for that to
compute this adjoined gradient so how do
you compute that well it turns out that
this can actually be done quite simple
because if you have the jacobian you
only need to transpose of the jacobian
and then you can solve this in a
two-step approach and that basically
adds almost no cost to it so
if yeah as soon as you have your
jacobian you can immediately do that and
get this gradient of the misfit versus
your model parameters p and this is two
very important useful applications the
first one is that you can use this to
determine the key model parameters of
the simulation typically we have many
model parameters and we don't know which
one is the most important one this is a
very simple example that all of you know
from physics this is the thinking of a
sphere stroke thinking problem and and
there's an analytical solution for that
that is shown here and what you can see
from the analytical solution is that the
radius of the sphere is to the power of
two so that's the most important
parameter and the viscosity of the
sphere itself is not important because
the exponent has factor zero and it
turns out that you can reformulate this
a little bit to compute the exponents
here of each of these parameters in an
automatic manner and then you only need
to know the derivative of the velocity
versus your model parameter and that is
something that we can get with the
adjoints methods here so we can
basically get that automatically for
this model and we can do one
computational step and you can
immediately get the scaling law out for
the sinking velocity of the sphere in
case you would have known that
for this simple model of course we know
that but for more realistic problems for
example in this case we have
maybe 50 model parameters and we don't
know which of those is the most
important one to for example control the
uplift velocity at the surface and we
can use this adjoin methods
to basically determine automatically
the most important parameters as you can
see many of those are close to zero so
they don't matter very much but some of
those have a higher exponents so those
are the ones that actually matter
now the second application of the
adjoint methods is to do gradient based
inversions and actually try to take a 3d
geodynamic model and fit it to the
observations at the earth's surface we
have done that for a yellowstone
magmatic system here where we had a good
relatively good starting model but the
velocities didn't quite fit the observed
velocities and then with a
gradient-based inversion we we perturbed
the most important of the key model
parameters and we managed to get a much
better fit
and what this basically does it changes
the viscosity of the lithosphere and the
wall at the sphere on your block a
little bit yeah so this kind of
inversions work very well in the case
that we have a good when we have a good
starting model but if we do not have a
good starting model uh
you will not obtain a good solution so
so that is still part of ongoing
research so just to to wrap up the
computer computing radiance is really
crucial in computational geodynamics
both for computing forward models and
for doing inversions and sensitivity
analysis uh most of the complexities we
have come from adding new physics and
rheologists you know so analytical
derivatives can be cumbersome uh but
automatic differentiation tools can
really help phd students to make oh
also people like me to hear to make much
faster scientific progress and julia
certainly the way forward we are working
on a range of packages to simplify
writing new codes and
and
much of that will probably be discussed
only next year because it's much vlog
and progress but if you want to look at
these
repositories feel free to have a look at
that thank you very much
thank you a lot i'm not letting sorry
boris thanks that's great uh and yeah
good to see that uh you're gonna make
everybody's phds much easier yeah
um so do you wanna i'm gonna show the
pigeonhole screen there were a few other
questions maybe we could pick a couple
off is that okay
yeah
so
um
one so there's a question here
um
about discontinuities and how
differentiating the world is even
justified you want to
see that one
there are a bunch of just
discontinuities such as coastlines
enough non-differentiability such as
albedo depending on glacier hut however
i think that's a question for ludovic
actually but uh
yeah i think well it kind of applies
across all the
the projects we can regularize it but
yeah
so the plasticity that we use is a
discontinuous
uh function as well so which which you
basically would switch on or off
depending on um
what what
whether the stresses are above the yield
stress or not
and
and that seems to work yeah
yeah of course
so another question that i see is can
patsy use gpu yes but he can use gpu
there has been actually a lot of work in
patsy to make a gpu portable i haven't
actually tried doing that and i don't
think it will
nearly achieve the same kind of
efficiency as ludavik has been showing
before so i think if you want to use for
the kind of equations we are solving
if you want to use the gpu then the
first thing i would do is look into the
parallel stenzel approach
but betsy itself has made a lot of
advances in the last decade or so to to
run efficiently on the gpu and many of
the examples actually uh running
so the
other question do you use the full
jacobian on the action of the jacobian
in fact in le mans we use the action of
the jacobian we do not have the full
jacobian but we have the matrix free
jacobian so that works um
yeah
okay
right yeah so let's in the interest of
time maybe we'll carry on with the next
talk which is going to be julian i think
um
a lot lotto boris and others you can all
go to um
pigeonhole and add some text answers if
you want to yeah um so
to follow the people there so
okay thank you
so let's go to see if we can add julian
and
get rid of boris so now we've got julian
and julian is a we're going to switch to
some ocean things i assume julian is
that right
yes indeed um thanks um thanks for the
introduction thanks for thanks for
having me
yeah thank you thanks for having me here
the most because i i'm not like um yet
um uh julia language uh user so that's
uh that's uh that's very uh uh i'm very
glad to be here with you discussing
those uh exciting topics the question of
whether or not uh we may benefit we may
benefit or need uh differentiable ocean
circulation models in the in in the
future um i'd like to to to talk about
ocean circulation models today so ocean
circulation models are one of those
numerical tools that we use in
combination with observations and
inverse methods in general as tools for
better understanding and monitoring and
forecasting ocean circulation and
obviously has many other
fields of
computational physics where
in this situation where we have this um
this cross-fertilization between machine
learning numerical methods and
computational physics this emergence of
scientific machine learning and and and
obviously this is posing a number of
questions to to to to traditional fields
so what i'd like to reflect upon in this
talk is is is maybe highlighting a bit
some of the aspects where machine
learning is is is now uh gradually
affecting ocean models and and and why
we may need uh to leverage uh
differential differentiable programming
in this uh context and also obviously
listing some of the some of the
challenges at the at the scientific and
community level so first the question of
really augmenting
ocean models with a trainable component
so there are many many things you may
think of doing with machine learning for
ocean circulation models and there are
maybe three obvious areas where people
are really putting quite some effort
right now this includes in particular
emulation for accelerating model
components the design of new um of new
components and in particular for
parameterization of missing processes
and also the the broad undertaking of uh
uh improving the representation of
uncertainties in those
in those models maybe with a bit more
detail the question of the acceleration
of model component is uh
something that is uh in particular uh
relevant when you have a a very cost
intensive sort of a component in your
code that you would like to port to gpus
and some and we have like some uh some
actually working examples not in
oceanography yet but working examples in
particular in atmospheric models where
um
heavy lifting sort of components of
codes can be can be ported to ship you
through ammunition leveraging machine
learning um the the the second area
where there's quite some effort at the
moment and and i guess you are here uh
very much aware of this is uh is is is
really the question of designing new
components with machine learning and and
the most and and in oceanography this is
this is this translates into this
question of
resolving improving the representation
of some of the turbulent processes that
we that we need to account for and in
particular
uh when it comes to ocean circulation
the question of the representation of
the the mesoscale eddy dynamics uh and
its impact on on larger scales and there
are quite some efforts at the moment and
large projects focusing on this and
there's a nice uh review uh last year
issued by uh zannah and bolton that
really shows um where just the sort of
status and state of the art in this uh
respect but beyond
um eddy closures there's a there's a
there's a huge uh realm of application
you could think of and in particular for
the representation of all the processes
uh at fine scale occurring at the
interface between the ocean and the and
the and and the neighboring a component
in the earth system
in the earth's system last uh area where
we see like uh lots of activity at the
moment or or excitement maybe there's
this idea that uh you could leverage
machine learning for for for really
trying to to account better for the
propagation of uncertainties in our
models and in particular for dealing
with them more optimally with the
information we can extract from ensembl
simulations so there's this idea that to
some extent we could leverage in
combination uh ensembles and machine
learning to try and move towards some
sort of uh an approximate focal plank
equation sort of approach uh for
describing um the evolution of the of of
ocean circuit condition um those are all
nice examples but i guess what i wanted
to um illustrate maybe and and reflect
upon in this talk today is the fact that
for many of those applications what we
what we need is to augment um existing
codes that may or may not be a different
with with extra components that can be
trained and and and what you want to do
obviously is to train those components
so that they achieve optimally some task
uh you want to do that through a
minimization of some cost function and
and and the key aspect is to consider
that there are two cases um here
obviously simple cases where um your
your your your cost your your training
loss doesn't involve the direct model
itself so that's probably pretty easy so
that's what people do when they leverage
existing database for for uh for for
optimize enclosures for instance and
there are other cases where you actually
really need
your forward solver to include your
forward solver in the evaluation and
ends in the minimization process for
your for your training loss and this is
how um in uh you you may you may like
translate the notion of end to end
training to to to up to um to
computational physics whether what we
may refer to as the solver in the loop
sort of uh um optimization of mobile
component um
so far that's that's pretty much an
abstraction and what i'd like to
illustrate in the in the rest of my talk
is um one specific case where we found
that uh solver in the loop actually is
uh um uh a very useful for for
optimizing um subgood closure so indeed
this example deals with
the question of um are using machine
learning for designing a subgrid closure
so all the equations that we're solving
they live in in a continuous world where
all the older all the scales are are are
known and obviously because we we have
like a finite computational resources we
can only describe a fraction of those
scales and because the dynamics is
non-linear we have terms that we need to
close and and and this leads to the the
well-known problem of um ad closure or
subject parameterization problems that
find many many um uh uh instantiations
in in in all the models in earth system
in earth systems sciences and we all
know that this is this is a highly
non-trivial sort of problem because of
many a good reasons and across the uh
over the recent years there's been more
and more
efforts for trying to tackle this sort
of problem with machine learning uh for
both them for the calibration of
pre-existing closures for their
acceleration or or even like for the
design of new component and this is what
i will be talking about today
um so do way how this is usually
approach is um you start by picking up a
source of data and you want this source
of data to be to be dense uh so most of
the time it comes from an existing model
at very high resolution that you like so
you choose your truthworthy
high resolution model cloud resolving
for the atmosphere submission permitting
for the ocean then provided you know how
to define a projection procedure for
comparing
some information coming from the
high-res model with your course
resolution solver you can formulate a
supervised learning problem where
you will try and learn this mapping
between the coarse grain quantity and
the missing flux
you can formulate that based on your
data set you train you learn you obtain
a model then you plug it back into your
into your ocean model and you pray
the reason why you pray is because we
need to understand that the problem with
we've tried to solve here is not exactly
the one we really care about
so let me be a bit more
precise here this is related to this
this notion that is well known in the in
the largely simulation community this
difference between what they call the a
priory skill of a closure
versus what we may call the a posteriori
scale of a closure a priori skill refers
to the ability
of a closure to actually predict at time
t the unknown term in the equations
while the posterior skill is what you
really care about so basically
knowing how your closure will impact the
solution as it evolves over time
and um what we what we did in a in a in
a in a study um submitted to to gems
earlier this year is really trying to
translate this difference between a
priori and a positive skill into two
different approaches for training two
different strategies for training um for
training an extra component for an ocean
model based on um really this this
ability of
predicting like the missing term versus
predicting the um
versus being being an adequate extra
component for improving the trajectory
of the model of a long time so that's
what we did and we did that in
particular in in a very simple flow uh
quasi-geostrophic turbulence
uh you all know those equations are um
uh i guess so we have like uh invariance
energy and strophe because of that we
have a we have um a specific like um um
sort of turbulent cascade that allow
both forward and stratified and inverse
energy cascade so that's a that's an
interesting um
flow for closures because it's actually
challenging even for uh even for
empirical closure and up to and up to
recently uh
really challenging for machine learning
based closures so provided we know how
to uh project information from the high
res to delores we're able to um to
formulate our
reduced equations and we will try and
learn an extra term that will
improve the reduced form of the
equations the way how we want to do that
is by
training a neural net and this neural
net will be the same in two experiments
one where we'll train the neural network
and a poster a loss based on a priori
criteria trying to make sure that the
prediction at time t for missing term is
optimal so without running the model
itself and another one where we actually
will try and optimize the parameters of
the closure based on the past and then
on a positive learning criteria where we
will compare the model solution as it
evolves all the time the neural net that
we're training here is very simple no no
no no fancy magic it's just a plain
plain
plain cnn without any any any fancy uh
new stuff
the results what you see here
on the top
left panel you see like the sort of
target we
we want to achieve in terms of this
typical distribution of
spatial distribution of vorticity and on
the right you see like the predictions
coming from different models uh on the
top empirical models and at the bottom
trained models coming from from machine
learning and what you see is that the
baseline sort of empirical solutions are
usually too diffusive uh while the the
the the the machine learning ones can be
either unstable or stable depending on
whether we use the priori or apostrophe
learning strategy so basically in a
nutshell the idea is that with a
personal relearning we're trying we're
able to actually improve uh drastically
the ability of ma of machine learning
model to actually um be a good closure
for for this type of flow and this
without changing anything in the actual
structure of the of the of the closure
i'll skip this uh slide we can come back
to this uh um if we have any questions
because i'd like to take one or two
minutes to uh reflect on what i think
are the the sort of issues and
opportunities that that our community
may be facing in the coming years um so
the first thing we need to really
acknowledge here is that
although we've presented like an example
um it's not clear to me yet whether uh
uh the benefit of a solver in the loop
sort of training approaches would
generalize to more realistic flow
configurations so we really need like
community effort for benchmarking and
intel comparing that sort of approaches
there's a very good example um presented
here in this paper recently submitted by
andrew russ to james and most
importantly we need to understand that
those those end-to-end training
approaches they will only be able we'll
only be able to leverage them for
over short windows because of the
complexity of the computational graph so
if we really want to train and to
optimize closures for climate relevant
sort of metrics that require long-term
integration of our models we will need
like a work around and other strategies
so um um uh solving the loop approaches
will not be the end of the will not be
the end the end of the of the game here
um one point i'd like to illustrate also
is the fact that um there's an
interesting connection between this
approach like
using the solver in the loop for
training a closure it's actually very
similar to deploying a strong constraint
four divar algorithm for optimizing the
neural net parameters so we have like
interesting
connections here that in the end
probably means that we could think of
leveraging directly observational data
for optimizing the model the model not
only the parameters but the formulation
of the model itself so this is something
that i think we need to reflect upon in
the future
obviously the most important problem
here is how we switch to differentiable
models so many groups including in this
audience have started like rewriting
entirely their code so that they could
leverage uh uh ad and and and the full
power of differentiable uh programming
uh for others uh we may think of uh
maybe using uh emulation and that's
something that we may discuss uh later
wrap up
i'm done thank you
very nice thanks julian that's fantastic
so um are you okay to go and look
briefly at
the
questions see if there any new ones that
are good to talk about um
i think everyone was
busy listening so there's one though is
there a role for emulators in creating
more efficient ensembles so i guess
that's a kind of
sort of
i think we're really at the at the
beginning of this um uh of this um idea
of using machine learning in combination
with direct models for accelerating our
ability to describe the evolution of
pdfs and indeed one of the one of the
things you may think of is using um
emulators for access access
accelerating the computation of
individual trajectories or you may also
think of using emulators for uh
optimizing the
the sampling of the distribution based
on some some representation of the
distributions there are some examples in
in very idealized um problems but not
yet to my knowledge to uh applications
to
multi-dimensional systems like the one
we're facing in oceanography
thanks great and i see in the youtube
chat somebody's mentioned surrogates.jl
was a thing we should all look at i
guess
that's the great thing about julia
carnage you always find these new things
in every every talk so okay so now i
think we're on to
laura nora why am i getting everybody's
names wrong sorry nora
so let me try and add
let me get rid of julian bye julian
let's add nora inora
and your slides so no so we're going to
go from grenoble over to the um the
rockies yeah so from the alps to the
rockies and uh
nora again is you're on the ocean side
you're going to talk about uncertainty
quantification and ocean
observing systems yeah
yeah
yeah thanks yeah so my name is noah
luzer i'm a postdoc at university of
colorado boulder and i'll talk a little
bit about how we can use differentiable
earth system models um and their air
joints for its uncertainty
quantification and observing system
design yeah and there's cressetta for
this talk we'll stay in the ocean and
and as junior i'm i'm not for this for
this talk i haven't used so i'm not
using julia yet but a fortran model with
its adjoint but the idea is to use
similar ideas for for differentiable
julia models
okay so
here's a little bit of background on
ocean state estimation or it's it's kind
of similar to 4d var data simulation
and this is the framework i'm working
within today so the idea is to
to
combine ocean observations and ocean
models in an optimal way so here on the
left we're looking at an example of um
of an ocean observing system in the
north atlantic it's called the olsen
array and the ozna beret
is monitoring
temperature salinity and velocity
yeah with these moorings so called
moorings and this happens along this
section from labrador to
the southern tip of greenland all the
way to
scotland here
so in terms of ocean observations these
instruments
are extremely densely spaced but you
still see their gaps right and these
gaps are certainly larger elsewhere in
the ocean so how do we
infer ocean properties and ocean
circulation
in these gaps away from the instruments
and this is where
ocean state estimation comes into play
so
an ocean general circulation model knows
about the equations of motion and
physical conservation laws so we are
filling these gaps in a way that
the resulting ocean state and
circulation is consistent with both the
existing ocean observations and the
physics encoded in our model
and practically this is done by solving
an optimization problem where you define
yourself a cost function j
um yeah on the on the space of uncertain
model inputs and this cost function has
two parts model data misfit is the first
part and the second part is
regularization
so um
yeah the optimization problem now
consists in finding the minimum of this
cost function because the
the minimum provides the best
combination of model parameters that is
most consistent with both the
observations and the model
so how do we find this minimum well we
can do gradient based optimization if we
have
you know if you have the adjoint
available um or if you have gradients
and this is exactly what the model
adjoins provides us with
so um
[Music]
let's go a step further let's let's
assume we've found this minimum right so
this best best guess um
of ocean of the ocean stayed in
circulation how do we quantify
uncertainties in this solution
and it turns out that you can
interpret
the deterministic ocean state estimation
problem that i showed you on the
previous slide in a bayesian context and
then bayesian inference tells us that
the posterior probability
distribution is given by e to the minus
j where j is the cost function
but it is essentially impossible to to
sample from this or to to compute this
this posterior probability distribution
by sampling methods just because
the control space or the the model
where this where this u live
lives is is way too high dimensional
it's typically 10 to 6 10 7 10 to 8 in
ocean state estimation so we have to
make some sort of approximation if you
make a gaussian approximation
you get a gaussian with mean equal to
the minimum of your cost function and
and posterior covariance matrix equal to
the inverse of the hessian of the cost
function
so and this makes sense right because
the hashing kind of consists of the
second derivative so in other words the
curvature so the more curved your cost
function is around the minimum the
better constraint is your solution the
smaller are the posterior uncertainties
so we want to get at this hessian
and again it's computational prohibitive
to compute a full hessian but what we
can do is to compute a low rank
approximation where we
compute the leading eigenvalues and
eigenvectors
so let's apply this
to a real world example and go back to
our o snip array in the north atlantic
so
to put all these instruments in the
water and maintain them over the years
it's a huge and costly effort
so this is the ocean beret project it's
a it's a large international project but
if you only count the funding that comes
from the u.s side it costs about 30
million us dollars to keep this
observing system up and running for only
five years so the takeaways ocean
observing systems are pretty expensive
to build and maintain
so it is critically to ask
how can we build efficient or even
optimal observing systems
how can we minimize redundancy between
these instruments
is this a good configuration or could we
maybe skip some of these moorings and
place them elsewhere
and one way to answer these questions
um is to use hessian uq because you can
say an observing system is optimal if it
minimizes the uncertainty either in the
model parameters or in some
important ocean metrics that you define
so i'll show you some results or some
work i did on this and yeah as i said
i'm using the mit gcm which is a an
ocean general circulation model coded in
fortran and it has an adjoint
so let's focus on first on on one single
observation up here um um this is yeah
and temperature observation at an old
snap mooring in the irc close to the
southern
southern tip of greenland here
so this map
um
predicts
that observing temperature at this
yellow location will predict uncertainty
will reduce uncertainty in wind
in all locations that are shown in red
and blue here
and wind is part or wind at every
surface model grid cell is is a subset
of
the uncertain model parameters that
we're trying to constrain
so in other words
the this this temperature observation
here this yellow dot does not only
contain
information about the local temperature
but also about other model parameters
and far away from the measurement
location
and this is um yeah this is quantified
via derivative enabled hash and uq
within the mrtgcm or the echo state
estimation framework
and what we're actually looking at here
is
actually the the first eigenvector of
the hessian that is associated with this
temperature observation and if you only
have one observation then the um the
only the first and only eigenvector
actually is um is given by essentially
given by the the gradient of the
temperature at this location to all
yeah to all uncertain model parameters
and there's only one derivative
appearing here because in this case i
used the linearized hessian or the
gauss-newton hessian this is something
that's
often done
another point to note is that
to predict to compute the uncertainty
reduction like here you actually don't
need to know the actual measurement
value at this location so you don't need
to know if the temperature
if the measurement will give you three
five seven degrees
um
the only thing you need to know is the
measurement location frequency and
uncertainty
so
this is this is this is i mean this is a
valuable property because you can
actually you know
predict the uncertainty reduction before
putting the instrument in the water
and then i want to make one more point
about this figure which is that the
spatial pattern of uncertainty reduction
that we see here can be explained by
ocean boundary wave propagation so there
are essentially two mechanisms at play
here in box one and box two i don't have
time to go into the mechanisms today but
the takeaway is that
um you know
hashing uq is not just a black box that
tells us oh uncertainty will be reduced
here and there
it also gives us dynamic insight looking
at these hessian eigenvectors you know
we can infer we can say something about
the dynamics and physics that um
you know that reduce the uncertainty
so let's now go a step further
and look at not one but three
temperature observations so the first
one is still our our usual one here in
the omega c
the second one is one off the portuguese
coast and the third one is between
greenland and iceland here in denmark
straight
and these three maps again show the
uncertainty reduction
that is implied by each of these three
observations
so we've talked about this map let's
look at this one the second one
it looks like the portuguese coast
observation is only sensitive to this
mechanism in box one but not in box two
right while the denmark's trade
observation it has a pretty similar
pattern of uncertainty reduction as the
omega c observation so now the question
is
what happens if we add either the
portuguese cost or the denmark's trade
observation to an existing irmingus
irminger c observation how much
information do we how much extra
information do we gain
by the second observation
and yeah we can we can look at the hash
and your q analysis so what hashing your
q
or
what it does for us is it gives us
orthonormal eigenvectors right so this
orthonormalization basically takes care
of um removing redundant information
so if we do this we this this
orthonormalization
we
and look at the denmark strait um we see
that a lot of the sensitivity of
information up here got removed right so
and so this tells us that the imaging i
see in the denmark straight observation
they
contain a lot of redundant information
while the portuguese coast observation
it looks the sensitivity pattern or
uncertainty reduction pattern
it looks pretty similar
like before and after orthonormalization
so that tells us these two
contain a lot of complementary
information
so in this example here
observing at portuguese course gives
gives more independent information at
observing at denmark straight
um so yeah the takeaway from the slide
is that you know hedging eq allows us to
assess um data redundancy versus
complementarity and since all of this
can be done
um
[Music]
before putting the instruments in the
water
you know it's useful it's a useful tool
for observing system design so instead
two minutes nor one yeah i think i need
only half
so yeah let me quickly wrap up so i've
shown you that you know we can use
differentiable models and derivative
enabled hash and uq to do a couple of
things so first of all we can deal with
high dimensional spaces of uncertainty
of uncertain model parameters something
that sampling methods mcmc methods alone
cannot deal with
and then we can along the way we get
dynamic insights on causes of
uncertainty reduction
and yeah we can we can use this also for
observing system design problems
and then as an outlook i would be really
interested in in trying some of these
things um and with yeah differentiable
julia models and but also maybe try some
more hybrid approaches where we you know
we can we can do stuff like graded
enabled mcmc that also work for more
non-linear problems where you cannot
just
um
yeah sample
or compute gaussian approximations but
more
yeah more more complex posterior
distributions
okay
thanks nora that was that was awesome um
so let's go just see if there are any
more
questions so um
so there's a question about how
computationally expensive is eigenvector
computation compared to a single
prognostic
model computation
yeah so i guess this
so in general
i mean you basic so i i mentioned i
actually only use the um the linearized
hessian so you essentially you only need
um
first derivatives so your question in
this in this case it boils down to how
expensive is an adjoint solved versus a
forward model solve and um
i mean theoretically i mean it it is
also connected to the fact um so to
something like called checkpointing
because we are like check so if you like
if you compute the adjoint right you you
basically you compute the um the
derivative starting like from you're
going like backwards
so you have to um since we're since it's
a time dependent problem you have to
kind of you always have to
you always have to know the the forward
model state at every time step so this
kind of makes it um a little bit more
expensive so in you basically have to
depending on your on your checkpointing
but it it will be maybe three times more
expensive than a forward motor run or
or more but i think there are actually
there are some other people here in the
audience who really work on
checkpointing so they can
yeah we'll have some we'll have some
talks specifically about some of the
technology yeah
so uh and then there's one more which is
how do you
orthonormalize the field did you use a
julia package i think you know
not yet yes
no so this was all using um the mrt gcm
which is which is fortran model but
yeah that would be would be a good thing
cool thing to try in the future yeah
well that's a good lead into um the
session that krishna is going to lead in
a minute which is kind of starting to
look at
tools and things like that so maybe
thank you um
ludovic boris julian nora um i think
we're going to start into the next
session
um
anybody should feel free to go onto a
pigeonhole and answer questions and
things um
but uh i think that was those were great
talks so thanks everybody um
and i'm gonna remove myself and hand
over to krishna now yeah chris could i
ask you to stay on and uh start your
talk right away if that's okay
okay i thought matthias was going first
but
it just needs a few more minutes okay
let me just uh
find my talk
i just have to do something where i
i think i stop sharing
and then i share i just have to change a
tab
and then share again
it's the wonders of
the sharing tool we're using okay so
here we go
and
and then i go and add to stream
right uh
let me say a word about you chris
despite you during the previous session
chris is a computational scientist at
mit and he has developed ocean and
planetary models and modeling tools that
are used by many many people
and he's going to now talk about his
latest creation ocean elegance in dj for
earth
excellent thanks krishna okay so um yeah
it's not really my latest it's a team
effort so um
but i'm going to talk about
oceananigan's which is a julia based
ocean model that um a bunch of folks at
mit have been and elsewhere have been
collaborating on developing it is in the
context of dj for earth i'm going to
talk about how we're starting to look at
how to do derivative um calculations
around this this framework so it's our
first foray into kind of applying
derivatives to julia code so shenanigans
is a
ocean modeling
tool developed entirely in julia and is
designed for non-hydrostatic hydrostatic
and shallow water type problems so these
are mostly rotating stratified
finite volume fluid problems it's all
open source software you can go to
github and take a look it's being
developed under a larger project known
as klima and
a lot of it is based on algorithms from
the mit general circulation model which
is the model that
nora just showed some examples from um
it is a you know github julia package
and so
there is you can go to uh your julia
reppel and uh add the package and then
start using it there is under the
github site a nice set of examples and
kind of getting started material that
kind of orients you a bit i'm kind of
going to
talk i'll show a couple of pictures but
then i'm going to talk more about how
we're thinking about
um
introducing some enzyme-based
differentiation into this and other and
uh different uh differentiation work
primarily in the context of dj for us so
just before that though
here's a couple of snapshots from
current
um ocean and again set up so
this is a
um
kind of proof of concept pilot run of a
global ocean circulation problem that um
simone silvestri is running on uh gpus
with ocean anagens at the moment um and
so this is kind of a recent uh result
this just so sea surface hype for anyone
who's
oceanographically oriented you know we
have some eddying gulfstream we have an
acc we have um equatorial waves so the
sorts of
um fluid dynamics you expect in the
large-scale ocean and that you see from
space if you look to things from space
where we go out in the field and measure
them um so it's kind of a got a lot of
the there's still some work to do to
make it kind of
up to speed with um state of the art
ocean models but it has many of the
dynamics that you would expect to see in
an ocean model um
at the other end of the sort of scale
spectrum this is looking at a um simple
2d
um
rarely been our convection problem where
i think we're either heating from below
or cooling from above not sure which um
it looks like we're heating from below i
think and um
just looking at
convective overturning and
non-hydrostatic dynamics so this is a
very small scales this would be like a
a thousandth of a pixel within this
large scale model um but the same kind
of um dynamical engine can do both of
these so shenanigans
is being developed as a sort of
fairly flexible library for doing uh
problems from you know these planetary
scale things down to these process scale
things which are all as we saw in kind
of julian's talk um things that come
into setting the overall climate of the
ocean
um and control you know how ocean
dynamics affects the planetary system we
all live on
so
i'm gonna actually delve a little bit
into kind of the technical nitty-gritty
we're gonna you know now we've kind of
had these overview talks we're gonna
talk a little bit about
um kind of some of the
detailed work within dj for earth um so
i'm going to delve into how we're
thinking about applying dj to for earth
type and enzyme and things to ocean and
again so the
ocean and again so i'm going to start by
just kind of showing a little bit of the
anatomy of ocean anigans the full code
base contains many parts um
and we're actually only focusing on some
um subset of those parts for the first
stages of the derivative and
differentiation work uh we're looking at
so this on the right and we're going to
look at some simple advection problems
that's what i'm going to
kind of walk through in a minute
um
but this on the right shows sort of the
full
um
anatomical structure of ocean anigen so
starting at the top you've got a julia
package and then there are these kind of
high level
abstractions we've that have been
created called simulations and models um
diagnostics io checkpoint restart here
is actually i just realized that's not
uh
checkpoint as in what krishna i think or
michelle is going to talk about later in
the kind of um
along the lines that uh nora spoke about
this is more um just a utility for
actually when you're just working with
prognostic models but there's some of
some overlap with what you need in uh
reverse mode ad as well so um
but the main picture the thing to get
out of this is there's a kind of upper
level of this of structure which is
around
kind of configuring
things for studying the ocean and doing
kind of
you know science level experiments and
then green there's kind of a lower base
layer of kind of all the tools you
actually need to do that and we've got
things we call abstract operators fields
grids um and then at the very bottoms
what's uh ka here is short for kernel
abstraction so this is a julia package
that lets everything run either on cpus
or gpus fell fairly well um and
the
the core of ocean anagons in terms of a
kind of numerical engine and the things
that we
want to differentiate are kind of time
stepper things these
fields which just
represent discrete spaces of um the
state of your fluid say temperatures or
velocities and then grids which actually
have um kind of you know
represent the the discretization a field
sits on top of and operators which are
kind of like
um simple um finite volume uh calculus
operations that that you can apply to
fields and grids um
and just as sort of aside in some of the
things i'll show the white things are
kind of things that
one sees in a bit of code that is kind
of written in
by a user of ocean and against the black
things are more under the hood um but we
you know just to give a sense from this
is really that you know it's quite a
large system and right now where we are
with things like enzyme is we're not
trying to kind of attack all of it in
one go we're trying to kind of work
through some um subset of this
so the problem we've started looking at
in the context of enzyme is really just
kind of the most
one of the most basic things you could
look at which is just
let's see what how can we um
get enzyme to kind of essentially digest
through this kind of stack of things
here but for a specific
um instantiation of the koto enzyme you
know sees the llbm back end so it kind
of knows what the instantiation is and
only has to worry about um things that
are sort of active um well that's what
we'd like you to do um so the simple
problem is just advecting with a
non-divergent discretized analytical
solution to the stumbled jar equations i
think um
sarah is probably going to show a little
bit of modeling work related to this but
these are showing analytical um
solutions so
uh the stumble jar experiment is a
classic
um kind of analytical paper that was uh
done in the early 50s that helped
everyone understand why there's a gulf
stream
you can solve it numerically you can
also
just
write out the kind of analytical
solutions that the numerical solutions
should
correspond to so this is showing the
analytical solution so you have
uh in the stumble jar experiment you
define a stream function so that's kind
of so we're looking down on a box of
water in this case i've set it so it's
like a thousand kilometers by a thousand
kilometers but the size is kind of
a free parameter in this um so you can
think of this as you know very crude
approximation to what goes on in a ocean
gyre where you have a western boundary
current like the gulf stream or the or
it's going this way if it's the gulf
stream or the kurushio
and that you have um
flow going
uh towards the east here and towards the
west here uh you have flow going north
here uh going
northwards all the way around you have
another kind of um
circulation in this direction uh
supported by the north-south flow so
um
and so this this analytical solution we
can actually then
put that into something like oceans and
we can think about
going back to our
um
kind of differentiation hat
um what it is what is it we would like
to have as be as a dependent variable an
independent variable in this code so in
our case we're going to just simply
first imagine putting a um
a die into this fluid concentration c
that might vary with space and time um
so we might put a blob of dye here and
look it carried through we can define a
dependent variable j which is simply the
flux of die across a little uh dotted
line here okay
so we define j as the transport of a
tracer c through a surface the the
dotted line and then we can ask things
like how is j or what we'd like to do is
how how is j sensitive to
the
um independent variable so in this case
it might be the
zonal flow or the flow yeah but this is
the flow vector um
or it might be the trace concentration
and the nice thing about the analytical
problem is
um
we actually for the flow fields we have
analytical definitions of these so we
can actually ask we can both kind of do
this numerically but we can also
interrogate the equations to sort of
compare with how we're doing against um
analytical solutions so um so our kind
of independent variables will be things
like a tracer concentration wind stress
so the flow field is a function actually
of the wind stress um and so these crop
up in the analytical equations so we can
kind of um connect the two
so
the sorts of things we're going to we're
exploring we have not completed doing
this yet but looking at with enzyme is
this notion of
you know in a
adjoint or reverse
mode computation we'd like to see that
the propagation of
sensitivity so the propagation of this
j influence so if you imagine a die is
carried forward through this line here
if you ask what is this sensitivity
of this
of the flux across this dotted line to
the die distribution earlier on you
expect that sensitivity that partial
derivative to actually propagate
backwards in time and we want to be able
to generate that automatically um by
applying enzyme to our codes we could
also do this in this case analytically
but the whole point is to kind of um let
enzyme find this for us so that we can
then do the sort and these are exactly
the sorts of um
problems that nora's been talking was
talking about with the propagation of
waves down the eastern boundary and so
on um there's a advective and a wave uh
part to what nora is looking at we're
going to look first at the effective
term but there are things you can look
at that are also uh wave-like in the
same framework so
um
you know some of the things we're
starting to look at are can we fully
automate this computing this numerically
all in julia
first using simple tape forms where you
know nor also mentioned saving
trajectories so you can reverse traverse
them in reverse mode
in
kind of the machine learning world where
you do this where you're thinking of
reverse mode as back propagation
typically you don't have to
think as carefully about how to scale
your checkpointing approach sort of in
an unlimited way um so you can sometimes
get away with a very simple tape kind of
way of recording or
some optimization but not um having to
really go fully to town on it in the
sorts of time dependent fluid dynamical
problems we really care about
um you need a highly sophisticated kind
of checkpointing approach and um
krishna and michelle are going to talk a
bit more about the actual under the hood
of this but what we want to be able to
do with these test problems is just
really um
show that
evaluate those approaches as we start to
implement them in julie and julia and
show that they can
uh be effectively we hope unlimited in
kind of their time span by having a
hierarchy of things and this is based on
um algorithms that have been you know
evolved over many years that
uh the argonne group involved in this
project are very experienced in um
just a tiny bit uh if i have time is
just to show sort of a little bit of
flavor of how we actually do this in
ocean again so i shenanigans i said had
these abstractions that we saw on that
um anatomy chart a grid a model a
simulation and then we want to kind of
fit that with an enzyme wrapper
these abstractions pretty simple so
here's you know what a grid looks like
for this um
um
stomal problem uh we kind of you know
just declare a kind of rectilinear box
with certain dimensions um we actually
don't include the grid parameters in
independent variables but liters okay
then a model
currently in oceans we
our non-hydrogenic model type has more
hooks for passive tracer advection um so
that's fluid
doing things when the fluid momentum and
pressure dynamics are turned off so we
can carry it around
then we can actually define essentially
flow fields and tracer concentrations
that are based on these analytical
formula from the stomal equation so i've
kind of shown some of the formula on the
right here
in the end it's julia code that we
implement this in um
and ultimately then where we want to end
up is just being able to kind of take
those building blocks the grid the model
and the initialization and simulation
and effectively end up with a code that
kind of says j is some function of these
things which um
which you know these are the ocean and
against building rocks in f we wrap
those in
kind of some outer function and then
feed into enzyme uh the request to kind
of compute sensitivities with respect to
these arguments so we're kind of getting
close to that we're not there yet but
that is kind of uh where we are and
that's that's kind of what i wanted to
show today
thanks chris um
so i don't see questions right now on
pigeonhole but i invite everybody to add
more questions there
but to interpret a question that's in
youtube chris how easy is it for
to get started working with ocean
elegance for someone who's not done it
before
um i think on the whole it's actually
fairly easy it is all in fact if you go
we had a workshop on friday at juliacon
and there's some videos showing greg
kind of
doing some setting up simple um problems
live in youtube um those are based on
mostly on stuff that's on the
documentation on the website so you can
also kind of do it without having to
watch him do it live but it's um it
shows that it's fairly straightforward
there's a few basic ideas you want to
get to terms with and then um
then you can you can start playing it's
designed so you can play with it
oh excellent well thank you so much
okay i will
now add math here one again
um
thanks christian
is a professor at dartmouth college
whose research focuses on the physics of
glacier ice and the role of ice sheets
in the climate system over to you
matthew
sure
so thanks everyone i'm going to talk
about something fairly similar to what
chris talked about but applied to ice
sheets
so again this is very collaborative it's
not just my work i want to make sure
that
valentin especially that has been
instrumental in this work
gets credit for it as well
okay so data simulation has been
used extensively over the past
30 years in glaciology because as
for
oceanography there is many parameters so
boundary conditions or initial
conditions that we don't necessarily
have observations of
so we like to use inverse modeling to
try to infer what they are
and so there has been a number of papers
over the years
the main primary application so far has
been to infer basal conditions we
observe the surface of glaciers very
well we can't observe what's happening
at the bottom
and under glaciers is where we have
basal friction going on so it's very
critical for us i should modelers to
have a good idea of how much stress we
should apply at the bottom
at the ice bed interface because that
determines how fast the glaciers are
flowing
there's been other applications where we
people looked at using the same approach
to infer the viscosity of the ice
especially of floating ice shelves
and then you know other applications
again but based on the same principles
so the idea i mean i'm sure we all
know what inverse problem is but if we
if we provide the model with um
a basal drag coefficient so we just
specify how slippery the bed is
then the model um f here can take this
boundary condition and tell us what the
ice velocity should be so this is a
glacier that's very
looked at in the communities called pine
island glacier so if i give myself a
friction coefficient that's uniform
that's the speed that i get so that's
surface speed and that's also something
we can observe that we have here at the
bottom so you see that if i take a guess
a random guess of what the basal
friction should look like
you see that my model looks nowhere near
what it should
when we look at observation so we want
to use we want to solve the inverse
problem where we have the output of the
model we have observations of the
velocity and we want to get this basal
drag coefficient
so to do that
people have basically been using the
usual joint approach while the manual
joint where you get the gradient of your
cost function that measures the misfit
between your observed and model velocity
and then you follow some sort of of um
decent
gradient descent approach and it works
pretty well
so this is my initial state where we
have
my initial base of friction here my
initial model velocity this is my target
and if we compute one gradient uh and
follow some some decent approach then
five uh five times five gradient
computations and we keep going on and on
you see that we end up with a pretty
good match
i may have another one so maybe not we
have a pretty good match between the
modern observations and we are able to
infer what the basal conditions should
look like
and it's very powerful we can do this at
the scale of antarctica
and so you have here the model velocity
to the left the observed velocity to the
right and you see that it's doing a very
good job and it's critical when it comes
to
future projections because we need to
get the flow speed right that's what
determines how much ice gets into the
ocean and raises sea level so we we
absolutely need to have
this capability
so as i said
this is mostly done in the community by
solving the
a joint analytically so we have our
forward model we have the joint model
and we compute the gradient and follow
that steepest
decent approach
but some models are now turning into
automatic differentiation to do this
because it has all sorts of benefits and
we can we can solve a couple pdes it's
just easier to do with ad
the model i'm using is called issm the i
sheets
and sea level system model and i've i've
looked into different tools to do this
to do to use automatic differentiation
the first one that i tried to use was a
tapenade which
is a great really awesome tool but it
works primarily for fortran
so i wanted to see how it would perform
with the c codes i rewrote um issm in c
with us a bit of a simpler simpler
structure
and it did okay but tapenade has all
sorts of of um shortcomings primarily
you need to patch the code like you need
to have thousands of of patches so it
didn't seem very practical at the time
and they used another tool that's based
on
object overloading called kodipak
and it really worked
really great so we compared the
performance of issm kodi pack in c plus
plus to
stream ice which is another model part
of vmit gcm written in fortran um
that's using another ad tool and we were
getting so here what you're looking at
are basically gradients
i don't need to go into the details but
you see that the
ad applied to the fortran code stream
ice gave very similar results to the
issm
ad tool even though it's a different
grid it's a different model with uh with
different settings we were getting a
very similar result so it works great
um but down the line we wanted we want
to do something that's a bit more
complicated what we want to do is run
the model over the historical period and
constrain our parameters using all
observations that we have not only
surface velocity but also surface
heights
also and over time we have time series
so with that julia with its capability
of of universal differentiation is is a
it's a very awesome tool again
especially the the machine learning part
where we could potentially use that tool
to help us better understand the physics
that is not well captured in models
so with what we promised we would do um
in the project dj for earth for the ice
part was to use explainable machine
learning to help us
uh with iceberg calving which is
pretty complicated with the the
current observations that we have
but also develop surrogate models uh
developed ice ocean-coupled
sensitivities by uh coupling dijus in
julia to ocean lane against that's also
in julian these are all things that are
impossible to do right now with the
current tools we have
so very exciting stuff but we're it's
only the beginning as you're going to
see
so the first part was to rewrite issm in
julia so that we can use these
capabilities
and i developed a new model called d
juice
that's based
on right now a simple 2d depth average
stress balance so it's not a full stokes
three-dimensional model it's a plan view
model that's
actually happens to be doing a very good
job for fast flowing eyes
and
the other goal was also to keep a
structure that's as close as possible to
ice sm so that we could we could cross
compare model results it's a lot easier
to debug it's a lot easier to
to go through all the steps um to
develop a new model from scratch
so the interface is very very similar
we have one single variable called md
that has all the properties what is the
geometry what is the mesh what are the
numerical parameters we need to use
um
to run the model and then the core where
we solve the partial differential
equations it also has a very similar
structure to issm so again for debugging
purposes
it's it's very very handy to keep that
so we have a big class called fem model
that has inputs that has parameters that
has elements
and we work with these data structures
to create um our stiffness matrix our
load vector
and solve our pdes so there are some
differences because now everything is in
julia not only the
pre and post processing but also the
core it simplifies a lot the structure
of the code so we don't need to have
input output files
um
we can just work off of that md variable
it's not parallelized yet but it will be
at some point
so i thought i would give you a quick
demo of of what this looks like right
now i worked on a jupyter notebook for
the first time which was pretty cool
so this this is what it looks like you
just load uh djuse
you create a model
so mds are variable that contains all
the information we need to run the model
and so can you make the font a bit
larger it's pretty easy let me see if i
think that like
yeah that says yeah also how is that now
okay so i create an empty structure that
has all the parameters that we want and
then i call a function called triangle
that is going to create a mesh for us
so if i do this you see that i have my
model md with mesh geometry mass
materials that are themselves objects
with their own fields that describe all
these parameters
and then we can we can plot anything
like here i'm just plotting the mesh and
you see this is what my mesh looks like
in glaciology typically we use
unstructured grits because we want to
have very fine resolution in capturing
these fine ice streams that are draining
ice from the interior of the ice sheet
to the outside so with unstructured grid
it's easy to have a variable resolution
of the model
which is why we do this
and so here i'm just sending all the
parameters we don't need to go into the
details but
our initial velocities our rheology
parameters so stiffness exponents basal
friction
boundary conditions
and then we just called we just call md
equal solve empty stress balance and
that's where the magic happens where we
create these data structures we solve
our partial differential equations that
are non-linear in the case of ice
because it has a non-linear reality so
we need to iterate a few times
and then at the end i just plot my
results my velocity and this is what the
result looks like so we are looking from
above
at a square i shelf so it's floating ice
we have a constraint here that's no
velocity and here we have water pressure
that's that's pushing the ice but the
ice is spreading naturally
um it's sort of a wedge
so that's why the velocity is increasing
and we get exactly of course exactly the
same results as what we would have with
with issm that's based on a c plus plus
code
so it works for square i shells but what
we really want to do is have a code that
works for complex geometries
so here's another example where i didn't
set the model with deduce i set it up
with issm
but
we prepared a package so that we can
easily port
models
initialized with with the c plus press
code issm and port them directly into
julia into djuce
so that's what i'm doing here what i'm
doing is i save the file called temp 12k
dot matt so it's a matte file
and i'm reading it font please oh sorry
good point
so i'm i'm just reading that i'm
creating a model based on that matte
file that is a matlab file
and you see we have a few warnings
because right now d2s does not support
all the functionalities but overall you
see that we can we can plot the
any field we have so we were able to
convert an matlab-based issm based model
into djs in julia so we can go back and
forth which which is super handy so here
i'm just plotting the bad topography and
the nodes are highlighted as black dots
so as you see we have a finer mesh
resolution along the shear margins here
over here so that's a pine island again
it's a big ice stream that's flowing
towards the coast this way
and we can solve a stress balance again
um
on complex geometries and this is the
velocity that we get that again looks
just like observation so um it's doing
the job
the next steps are now to embed this
into an enzyme
routine so that we can invert now we can
get the the
sensitivity of a cost function which may
measure the mismatch between
observations and models but other things
so we want to we want to get the
sensitivity of this cost function with
respect to
the model parameters that we don't
control well so using using an enzyme
so
if i scroll down a little bit we hear
what
what i'm defining is that my cost
function that takes in
that takes as input parameter uh my
model md and a friction so let's just
this what this function does it solves
the stress balance based on the friction
that we provided and then
gets
we get we return the square root of
it's basically
root mean square error between the the
observed velocity and the model velocity
and so that's that's what's returned
so we get our initial cost function and
then we run this into enzyme where um we
basically have alpha our friction
parameter and we want to get the
gradient of that cost function with
respect to alpha by using the autodiv
function
at this point this is running but it's
very very very slow so the next steps
are to improve
the performance of of that that function
and then play with it and see see how it
performs
great that's all i have thank you
matthew for
looking at um
pigeon
[Music]
the one question is should you be should
it really be deduced.jail you keep
referring to d juice
um
yeah i like the name it doesn't have to
be that name but uh that's what we went
with it's for julia
ice model and he's for different chippew
yeah i like the name yeah perfect okay
uh
that's it thank you matthew thank you
krishna
i will remove you now and add our next
speaker
hey um sarah williamson is a
graduate let me add you
there you go sarah williamson is a
graduate student at the university of
texas and she's going to talk about 84
adjoints
yeah so hi everyone my name is sarah i'm
going to go over a very brief little
tutorial where i'll be showing you how
we can actually use enzyme to calculate
the adjoint variables and my model is
going to be very simple and i hope
they'll be easy to understand so
let's see okay
so the physical model that i'm going to
be using is the stomal three box ocean
model so as you can see it just has
three boxes
this is a really simple ocean model that
demonstrates thermohaline circulation
between the three boxes um thermohaline
is just a fake
excuse me a fancy way of saying that the
forcings come from a gradient a density
gradient that's driven by temperature
and salinity differences so every box
has a temperature in a salinity this
generates a density and then the density
gradient drives the circulation
despite being such a simple ocean model
we still have quite a few different
equations that go into our forward run
so i have equations for the densities of
the three boxes i have an equation for
the transport and then i have equations
for the time derivatives of the
temperatures and the salinities of the
three boxes so all in all this is a
total of 10 equations and
this is really like as dumbed down of an
ocean model as we can make it like
there's no wind stress there's no
coriolis forest this is really just
bare bones ocean and it still is
quite a bit in the forward run
and so the sensitivity like a lot of
people have spoken about using the
adjoin to calculate the sensitivity the
example that i'm going to be doing is
let's pretend that we want to know
the sensitivity of the final temperature
of box 1 to the initial temperature of
box 2. by choosing this example we've
already chosen our cost function which
other people have also talked about so
my cost function is this j of x of t
where x of t is the state of the system
at a time t my state is a six by one
vector i've got temperature one
temperature two temperature three
salinity one salinity two salinity three
and this is really just this inner
product of a unit vector with the final
state so this is
genuinely just returning to me the final
temperature of box one since that's the
first entry in the state vector
and then theoretically the sensitivity
that i'd like to calculate
would be found via this gradient it
would be the derivative of this cost
function with respect to the initial
state of the system
but i can't really take a derivative of
a function that only depends on x of tf
so what we're going to do is we're going
to use enzyme to calculate this value
and a bit computationally of what i'll
do is we'll run the forward model with
the steps compute densities compute
transport
update temperatures and salinities and
i'll just run this for however many
steps
and then we'll run enzyme backwards to
calculate the desired gradient and i'll
talk a bit about what i mean by running
enzyme backwards
and so how is the sensitivity actually
calculated so given our cost function
we're going to define something called a
lagrangian this is really just a fancy
way of getting at the gradient that we
want to calculate and so within this
lagrangian uh math calal
we have two new variables we have mu of
t which is what people have been
referring to as the adjoint variable um
so really the adjoint variable is just
this lagrange multiplier i also now have
something called capital l capital l is
the forward step so capital l will take
x of t minus delta t to x of t
um and that that's all that it's doing
so that's encapsulating like the density
transport time derivative update
and our goal
will be to find the minimum of this
lagrangian which is where the gradient
is zero right because if we want to find
a minimum what you do you take a
derivative and you set it equal to zero
and all of this leads to something
called the adjoint equation so we have
one two and three
and the average equations give us a
really nice easy way to step backwards
with these adjoint variables these
lagrange multipliers so if i set this to
0 and i solve it for mu of tf
i get the first last adjoint value and
this is what i mean by running enzyme
backwards because we're starting at the
final time and running backwards to the
initial time and since my cost function
is so simple i can compute this gradient
by hand this will just be that unit
vector in the first direction
the adjoint equation with the
intermediate steps so like the times
between the initial time and the final
time give me a way to go from mu of t
plus one back to mu of t
um and then this final adjoint equation
really tells us exactly the sensitivity
that we want to we want to know about
the model so this is what we're trying
to get at um
and then the next one like logical
question would be to ask so where does
enzyme come into play in all of this
enzyme will be calculating for us these
two actions
um so the action of the jacobian of our
forward set acting on the last adjoint
variable
and we can kind of think about like why
this would be so complicated to do by
hand even for such a bare bones ocean
model like
this l is computing for me a bunch of
different interconnected equations and
taking a jacobian of that by hand would
be
potentially doable but rather
complicated and enzyme 80 in general
makes this
very easy to do which is really nice um
and then we can just very briefly think
about like what does this gradient
actually tell us about the model so
this gradient tells us by how much we
would expect the final temperature of
box one to change if we perturb the
initial temperature of box two so this
is that sensitivity
um it's really easy to see this
explanation with a taylor expansion so
if i
expand with a small perturbation epsilon
around my initial state then you would
expect it to be approximately j at this
initial state plus the perturbation
times
this jacobian which is exactly the
sensitivity that we're going to
calculate with enzyme
um and here when i like i mentioned
before j is really only dependent on x
of tf so this is really saying like if i
perturb my initial condition and i run
it forward to the final state um this is
what that's saying
and this will also if i rearrange this
and solve for
the derivative of j with respect to the
initial state this gives me a really
easy way to check that the gradient that
enzyme has computed is correct and this
is a good rule of thumb is to check your
gradients um so specifically as i take
smaller and smaller perturbations i
would expect that this approximation
will converge to the adjoint value that
we're looking for
um and so now
i would also have a jupiter notebook uh
with just
like the just the example enzyme
calculation so first i have here the
models of the sorry the equations for
the model
um so i have an equation for transport i
have equations for the densities of the
three boxes
and then i have equations for the time
derivatives and the time derivative step
depends on if my transport is positive
or less than or equal to zero at the
given t so at any step i'm only really
looking at one set of six uh
and so that is what that is i've already
added in the necessary packages i
believe or i maybe didn't okay
um so this box is just going to be
adding in constants that i see in my
equation so like the volumes this t2
star gamma and so on
so nothing super exciting happening
there
we set up functions that will compute
the steps in the forward step right so i
have a function for density sorry a
function for transport a function for
density and i have a function that
computes these time derivatives and then
we also within that have a sort of euler
step to get the next state of the system
and then i have a function that will
compute for me of states of the system
so this is all i'm going to do with this
is i'm going to run the forward model
however many steps i've given it here
it's referred to as m
and then i store these
in a place that i can look at them later
to feed the enzyme
and then i have another forward function
and this is where this is what i'm
actually going to be given the enzyme
it's doing the exact same thing it
doesn't store any states though so one
of the things we might notice is that
it's a function of both its input and
its output this is because enzyme takes
a derivative of the output or say a
derivative of the input or sorry
the derivative of all the outputs with
respect to an input uh it doesn't return
anything this is just what i'm going to
be giving the enzyme
and then i have a function that actually
does the 80 step and so this autodiff
is where we call enzyme to act
to take a derivative of this forward
function for ad
and so for example like i've wrapped
duplicated around in now and dna now i'm
giving it d and now initially as zeros
because what enzyme will do because i
wrapped this in duplicate is is it says
i'm telling you that hey i want you to
take a derivative of the outputs with
respect to this input and then
we'll store that in dn now
and so that just
is what enzyme is doing
and then
this will just run my forward problem
and so i'm running it for 10 000 steps i
have a dt of 10 days and then i have
some initial condition
this is more running enzyme once so as
you can see i have 80 old here is that
unit vector this is what i had said in
my slides that that first adjoint
variable is the derivative of my cost
function and it just ends up being this
unit vector in the first dimension first
direction side
um takes a sec to run it the first time
and then we can just run enzyme back the
rest of the way so this is me just
repeatedly running that 80 step function
until i get back to the initial
condition
and then we're done so now we've
computed the sensitivity we can look at
it it doesn't mean anything at this
point right because it's just a number
um and so what we can do is we can
actually do that computational
approximation using the taylor
derivative
uh so what i have here is just a block
that will for increasingly small step
sizes it'll run the forward model to the
end um
and then i will take the taylor
approximation of the gradient which is
the
unperturbed minus the perturbed over
epsilon
and then i store that i'm not storing
anything else here
and what will happen is then i can plot
the difference of the adjoint variable
with that taylor approximation and i go
one step further and i divide
all of this by the adjoint variable just
so that we can see a percent difference
rather than just a
actual difference it makes it a little
bit easier to compare what enzyme found
what the taylor approximation found
and you can see that as i take smaller
and smaller epsilon we get down to a
difference of about 10 to a percent
difference of about 10 to the minus six
so enzyme has done
a very good job computing our
sensitivity um
i also wanted to mention like some of
the differences like other people have
talked about
really
a lot more sophisticated ways of using
the adjoint method
so for example i stored all of the
states in my system this is something
that you cannot do in an actual ocean
model and other people have mentioned
checkpointing so this is where you would
need to actually implement checkpointing
instead of actually storing every single
state but since this is such a simple
model i just
i keep everything um and other people
have also mentioned that there are other
ways to use the hydrate method right
like i didn't need to look at the
sensitivity to an initial condition you
can also look at a sensitivity to a
parameter or you can try to do data
assimilation with the audrey method so
there's a lot of different ways that
this can be used but in the i guess the
whole point of mine is that enzyme makes
it really easy for us to actually
calculate these sensitivities um
and yeah that's that's my whole talk so
hey great talk sarah um
question um is your demo on github
somewhere to try
yeah so there will be a demo on github
it should be up within the next few days
for people to play around with
great and could you talk about what you
plan to do next
what we're going to do next yeah
so
i mean i'm going to work on
i'm going to help get ocean again
running with enzyme hopefully so their
goal is to add enzymes to better ocean
models right because this three box
model is not
it's not really a true ocean model in
any sense it's just kind of a toy model
for us to play around with and see that
insight works
check capabilities
okay um thank you so much
um with that i'll hand over to chris
hill
uh to play uh billy moses's video for um
on enzyme.jl
okay so let me try that so i'm going to
add
you know add billy's video to the stream
can somebody i'm going to press play
i haven't
checked so krishna can you confirm that
the audio works when i do this i haven't
checked this before so let's see okay
ready go i'm william moses and today
i'll be talking to you guys a little bit
about enzyme.js
the work on enzyme is not just the work
of myself but a much larger group of
people
in this talk i'm just going to be giving
a quick overview to enzyme there's a
wonderful talk coming up on wednesday by
tim gimmick going into a lot more detail
chris i think the audio is lost could
you add yourself to the stream please
sorry
i didn't know that happened sorry
let me rewind and we'll try again yeah
take two okay billy messes here we go
i'm william moses and today i'm gonna be
talking to you guys a little bit about
enzyme.js
the work on enzyme is not just the work
of myself but a much larger group of
people
in this talk i'm just going to be giving
a quick overview to enzyme there's a
wonderful talk coming up on wednesday by
tim gimmick going into a lot more detail
so to begin as we saw earlier
derivatives are really really useful in
scientific computation especially here
in the context of earth science modeling
so what's really neat is that it turns
out that derivatives specifically the
ones that we want actually can be
generated automatically by fun program
transformation tools so suppose we have
here on the left this relu3 function
that takes in an input and then returns
the corresponding output we can run it
through some ad transformation that
generates first a new function this grad
value that now computes the equivalent
of the derivative
there exists three typical styles of
doing automatic differentiation the
first of which is create an entirely new
domain-specific language where every
single operation in that language is
explicitly designed to be differentiated
examples of this and practice include
tensorflow pytorch or diffutaci this
works really nicely if the dsl that
we're aiming to target into matches
almost exactly the types of operations
that i have in my original program
the second approach is known as operator
overloading in essence the goal of this
is rather than making it an entirely new
language we're going to make specific
operations inside the language be
differentiable as an example here we
have our regular float64 type now we're
going to come up with a new dual of
float64 type and every operation that we
previously wanted to define on float64
like add and multiply we're going to
make new versions of this on the dual
version of it now
not all of the functions that we want to
use especially those that call external
libraries or c functions or whatever
else are going to be type extensible to
be able to handle both the original
float64 and this new dual of float64 so
there's still some amount of rewriting
that you may have to use to handle these
non-standard versions of this and julia
as an example some versions of this
include reverse tip tail for reverse
mode forward diff dot jail for forward
mode id if you want to use c code adept
as an example of an operator over
learning tool and jax is an example of
this inside of python that emulates
numpy style operations now we've
modified our value 3 function and most
of these operator overloading tools when
you're doing reverse mode have to first
run a version of the computation where
it looks at every single operation that
you're doing and stores all of those
operations that you're running on a new
instruction tape then when i want to go
ahead and compute the actual derivative
it interprets every single style of
those instructions on the tape to be
able to compute the overall derivative
and of course doing this sort of dynamic
recomputation and storing the values to
be later interpreted in practice also
can be quite slow
the third approach is known as source
rewriting examples include kind of zy
code inside of julia or specifically
julia ir top not for c code among a
couple of others the goal here is we're
going to take in our original input
program statically analyze it and emit
now new source code that contains just
the definitions of the grading function
unlike the previous one you don't have
to do any dynamic reinterpretations
since in practice you can just go ahead
and run the code of course there's going
to be some time for the sake of
compilation
but in a contrast you also need to make
sure that all the code that you want to
be able to run is available to these
source rewriting tools
now regardless of which of these three
style approaches that you go down all of
these tools tend to follow the same
typical approach so first i have my
language in this case julia um we have
our ad tool that's designed for that
language doesn't matter which of those
three and we emit new julia code and
then we go down the typical compiler
pipeline in this case the ad tool is
specific both to the individual language
and also operates entirely on the source
code basically as written before it goes
through any optimization procedures
now in practice that's not necessarily
the greatest thing so we've got this
magnitude function here that takes in a
vector of float64s and computes the
magnitude and of and time we have this
normalized function that normalizes the
vector in o of n squared time
specifically it's oven squared time
because we go through every index of the
array and we also compute the magnitude
there and since this takes of n time
we're doing that n times total runtime
of n squared
now any reasonable compiler worth that
salt should be able to figure out for us
that this magnitude function is the same
in every iteration it's able to hoist it
out and reduce the run time from o of n
squared down to simply o of n since
we're only calling the magnitude
function once if we were able to have an
av tool that doesn't actually work like
all those existing ones in practice
where those existing aed tools again
have to operate before
any optimizations come into play let's
see how that magic ad tool might work so
once again we have that original
function we optimize it then we do a d
on top of it and the way that in this
case reverse mode ad works is in essence
whatever you had as your original code
you mirror it or you reverse it to
compute the corresponding derivative so
whereas we had the magnitude function
outside the loop to begin with now we
have the gradient magnitude function
also at the end of the loop
but unfortunately that isn't actually
how these things are implemented in
practice these existing ad tools have to
operate before any optimizations we have
this magnitude function once again
inside the loop we do the
differentiation immediately now and we
have the gradient magnitude function
again inside the loop
we now see if we can run the
optimization after the fact and hoist it
outside but it's not legal to do so
specifically because the gradient
magnitude function actually calls
uh with this loop local variable d res
and since that variable's defined inside
the loop we can't hoist it outside the
loop so the real sort of moral from the
story is that if you're able to instead
of those existing approaches
differentiate after optimization you can
potentially create asymptotically or
just generally faster gradient code
and that's exactly what enzyme is
designed to do unlike those existing ad
tools which all operate one on an
individual language and at the source
level the goal of enzyme is to push
differentiation as far back as possible
in particular our goal is to be able to
push it inside of the lvm intermediate
representation where a huge amount of
all these existing optimizations are
done now by working on the llvmir we're
now able to work alongside the
optimization pipeline in particular
after existing optimizations are brought
also as a neat side benefit in addition
to the fact that we're able to of course
go ahead and say differentiate julia
code but we're able to differentiate any
code that's statically compilable down
to llvm so we can differentiate see c
loss code fortran rust swift whatever
you like as long as it's compilable
into lvm we're able to differentiate
that lvm
from here the first result that we got
which was presented at nerves 2020 is
let's just do an ablation analysis of
the effectiveness of running ad after
optimization actually works in practice
so we took our original enzyme pipeline
where we actually run optimizations
first we also took a reference pipeline
that tries to emulate the behavior of
these other ad tools specifically by
running immediately with no optimization
running first so if we compare both the
enzyme pipeline and that previously
mentioned reference pipeline on average
we get a 4.2 x speedup simply by
running optimizations before any ad
process
and we look across this which this is
the microsoft advent tweet which is a
relatively standard suite which has some
machine learning code such as some lstm
bundle analysis and gmm these pieces of
code get a regional speed up 2x say 2x
say like 5x or so we also have some
integrators so we have an euler
integrator and an rk4 integrator which
has a bunch of like macro expansion
template equivalent bits and we see
there's a really big gap right here
partially because there's a huge amount
of things to go ahead and optimize
inside of that through all those macro
expansions in the light finally we have
both the fft test and brussels raider
test and it turns out an fft was
handwritten to be super duper optimized
to begin with so doing any additional
optimization in the compiler prior to 80
didn't make as much of a difference
whereas here makes a huge difference and
for your typical machine learning codes
you make a still fairly sizable
difference leading to that 4.2x speed up
on average
now with that little intro to what
enzyme is generally let's talk about
enzyme.jl since this is julia khan after
all what enzyme.jl is specifically is
its julia bindings to the overall enzyme
ad framework which again recall can work
on any lvm based language not just julia
the bindings themselves are actually
built off of gpu compiler.jail which is
a wonderful framework for doing general
compilation which includes in this case
not just gpu code but cpu and other neat
pieces of code inside of enzyme.jl in
particular we expose both forward mode
80 and reverse mode ad what's really
neat about enzyme jl specifically in a
julia context is that unlike a lot of
other ad tools it's able to handle
mutation it's able to handle parallelism
both from a cpu context as well as from
a gpu context and in particular both amd
and cuda gpus as well as a lot of other
pretty neat stuff and as alluded to
earlier through the benefit of both
static analysis and optimization we're
able to get very very fast in particular
on scalar aid ecos
so we can actually take a look at how
this works in practice and compare it
against some of the existing tools in
the julie ecosystem you have this simple
taylor series you can run it within
enzyme for both forward mode and reverse
mode and you get roughly 30 milliseconds
and that's actually even faster like the
reverse mode enzyme is actually faster
than calling the four diff dot jl which
is itself faster in this case than zyga
which is itself even faster than calling
on defractor you can also compare this
to the equivalent code inside of jax and
it turns out to be a lot faster than jax
in particular not only is the time here
faster but you'll note here that this
order of number of iterations is one
order less than all these other ones
because it ran out of time to run and
this is the time that i cut it off the
python here code for jax is shown as
follows jax also has a high level
primitive for a for loop which isn't
exactly what the style of code is for
these other pieces but if you chose to
use that specific high level primitive
you get something a lot faster but still
not nearly as fast as these other things
which is pretty neat so talked a little
bit earlier about all the cool sides of
enzyme now of course enzyme is
continuous work in progress so there's
naturally a couple of sharp bits so as
mentioned earlier enzyme is built off of
gpu compiler chart trail which gives it
a lot of really neat stuff but in
contrast there's a lot of stuff that
also provides this limitation so
specifically if you have any code that's
gpu bio code in other words there's no
mutation you tend not to use a lot of
global variables etc that code tends to
be relatively well-formed and easily
differentiable by enzyme in contrast if
you have more generic or type unstable
code that's code that's not typically
well handled by gpu compiler which we're
actually extending to be able to make
sure that all of these things work
inside of it so the gist is
if you have code that's type stable and
insert that sort of fear you're probably
good off but if you have anything with
type and stabilities you're reaching the
line where there'd be dragons and may
not necessarily be full support yet but
we're continuing to add more support for
that as time goes on a couple of other
things there are some parts of julia
that tends to call into external
libraries we need the definition or a
custom derivative equivalent of those to
be able to go ahead and differentiate it
we have fallback support for typical
blas calls but we haven't yet
implemented that for lapack but
hopefully there's a pr standing for that
and that'll eventually come similarly uh
we don't actually integrate right now
with chain rules all of the derivatives
are actually generated from the lvm ir
itself as opposed to someone having to
go and manually specify the derivative
for all of those pieces so if you try to
use say a chain rule style rule and it
doesn't get registered it's because it
doesn't use chain rules right now
there's actually some ongoing work on a
precursor chain rule style system with
an enzyme called enzyme rules which
hopefully will eventually hook up with
that but currently doesn't exist and
will hopefully relatively soon in the
future moreover uh if you do use certain
styles of internal allocations in the
functions that you're trying to go ahead
and differentiate we don't yet have full
support for all the types of things
inside of julius garbage collector so if
you use certain types of allocations
inside the function that you're trying
to differentiate you may hit that in
progress support which is not yet fully
supported as julius garbage collector
has a lot of really interesting things
that i'm sure someone else at julia khan
can talk at length about some of those
interesting pieces
a couple of other relatively interesting
bits enzyme is one of the first tools
actually to be able to differentiate in
reverse mode arbitrary gpu kernels and
that actually turns out to be because
differentiating arbitrary gpu kernels is
really really hard and there's three
reasons for this the first of which is
just generically differentiating
parallelism
itself even independent of the gpu is
hard and can quickly lead to incorrect
results second reason for which is that
there's very complex performance
characteristics on the gpu that can make
it relatively difficult to synthesize
efficient code to run on the gpu and
moreover there's very specific
requirements on what is the total amount
of things that you're allowed to use on
the gpu that if you exceed that it'll
prevent your gpu kernel from running at
all talking just about parallelism to
begin with imagine we have here this
sample code that does a parallel four
across one through ten iterations and
for every iteration sets an index of an
array to equal the same value
now
this value is read in every single
iteration which is completely fine since
there's no potential contention on top
of it besides the fact that all the
threads would read across it so in some
sense this is a read race or a
concurrent read however you'd like to
say it the problem though is if you want
to go ahead and do the derivative of it
you'd see that you'd have the
corresponding reverse pass parallel for
loop unfortunately now as we're adding
up the derivative partial derivatives
into the differential d val whereas we
had a concurrent read in the forward
pass we now have a concurrent right in
the reverse pass and if you have
multiple things that try to write into
the same location at once in parallel
you will quickly get wrong answers
the second of these problems i was
alluded to earlier is that the gpu has
very specific constraints all the types
of things that you're allowed to use and
the types of things that are fast in
order to use so on the gpu there tend to
be three different styles of memory that
people like to talk about the first of
which are registers those are per thread
there's not a lot of them but they're
super duper fast so everything that you
can put inside of registers you want to
be able to do so there is one caveat to
that though which is if you use too many
registers at the same time it limits the
number of things that you can run in
parallel so keeping that in mind
having as much inside of registers as
possible will make your code run
exceedingly fast
the second type of memory is known as
shared memory so whereas registers you
couldn't actually see data from one
thread to another shared memory actually
allows you to do that within a specific
group of threads there's a lot more of
it there's now on the order of say
kilobytes that's supposed to only go to
bytes like that previous requirement for
registers if you use too much shared
memory it'll limit the total number of
things that can run in parallel and
still moderately fast not nearly as fast
as using just registers but if you do
need to do some sort of communication
across different threads or you just
need more memory share memory is a good
place to do it
global memory is the final type of
memory that people tend to care about on
gpus there's a lot more of it on the
order of gigabytes uh if i were to say
buy a new 390 and nvidia advertises to
me you've got 12 gigabytes of memory on
your gpu they mean you have 12 gigabytes
of global memory there's a lot more of
it obviously and it can be seen in use
by everyone which is pretty nice but it
tends to be very very slow and a lot of
typical kernels especially that haven't
necessarily been super duper performance
engineered tend to be bottlenecked by
the total number of read and writes to
global memory so if you do want to write
a fast program you want to shove most of
your work from the right side into the
left side type of memory as possible and
then you'll end up with a more
reasonably efficient kernel
and the way that we actually go ahead
and resolve those two problems with both
the parallelism as well as the memory
card key is actually to solve them
together so specifically if you already
have that super duper fast thread local
memory we can also give you a super
duper fast way of resolving the races
which is there is no race so we just do
a non-atomic load and store and that's
the fastest thing that you can do
now if you have the same memory location
across all threads as an example
sometimes with straight memory you can
actually do a parallel reduction which
well again not nearly as fast as just a
non-atomic load in store since there is
some amount of communication here still
is moderately efficient to be able to go
ahead and run
and finally if you have something else
where you have no idea what's going on
as an example as is the case with say
global memory you can always fall back
to an atomic load in store and it'll
maintain correctness and the sort of
like key takeaway here is assuming you
had a fast program to begin with then
you'll also end up with a reasonably
fast derivative to begin with because
the similar properties where you try to
shove most of your stuff into the faster
memory means that you'll have most of
your work again no faster way for
solving races
now we took all of that stuff and wrote
a whole suite of both ad specific and
gpu specific optimizations where the
full list is actually in our gpu paper
and a c of uh 2021
and we actually show that through the
use of not just those pre-existing lvm
optimizations but these novel ad and gp
specific optimizations are actually able
to speed up the runtime of these
differentiated kernels by several orders
of magnitude and more specifically
prevent them from just instantly ooming
as soon as you try to run it so in this
benchmark suite of six large-scale
benchmarks including both md or rockum
and buddha or nvidia kernels as well as
both julia and say c plus plus as
language inputs five out of the six of
these large scale benchmarks um or
otherwise fail to run instantly if you
don't turn on any optimization unless
turning on optimization let's actually
have your code run we have a couple of
examples here of how you might go ahead
and run it again both for cuda.jl and
indeed.jail the full version of these
codes are available at the link on
github below
and we have a lot of other really fun
ongoing and upcoming work so not only
did we handle all the wonderful types of
gpu parallels but we actually extended
it and since we're already inside of a
common core infrastructure we can
develop a common core infrastructure for
any type of parallelism be it gpu
parallelism uh cpu thread parallelism
distributed or like mpi style
parallelism uh where the the gist is you
basically want to reverse the dependency
structures and then as long as you have
nice things for both caching and race
resolution you can generalize that this
work is actually going to appear at sc22
so if you want to handle some wonderful
mpi julia tasks at threads we got you
thank you so much
okay
so
krishna um yeah so there is a question
or packages like linear algebra and
other things in this std lab
differentiable by enzyme so i don't know
about stdlib but i can talk about linear
algebra
i know that there's support coming in
in enzyme for blast and lapac and so on
and once it's there in
in enzyme proper it will be coming to
enzyme.jail as well
i think that was the
only question um
so uh without further ado i'm going to
kick you out chris and add michelle
hello
michelle is a computer scientist at
aragon national lab and he's going to
talk about autodesk extensions for
american simulations and julia over to
you michelle
yeah our mission in the dj first project
was to do autodiv plus x so
what is meant by that julia from very
early on had great ad support he had uh
forward div reversive
in very early versions
and
then came zygot defractor we have today
and
there are also other new ad tools
coming along but the question was what
if suppose you have an ad tool what else
do you need in order to differentiate
the kind of codes that we have
in this symposium
and has been
as the previous talk has been about
enzyme um it turns out that we will
probably be using uh enzyme a lot and
that's why also valentin and billy are
on this talk too since they helped us
out uh whenever we had to interface with
the
ad tool
um also summer student treyas
joined this project for this summer and
helped us out to develop an example code
so what are extensions for ad what do
you mean by that so you have an ad
tool
and then you want to for instance do
activity analysis so which
computational paths of your code are
actually active and need to be
differentiated this is being taken care
of by enzyme
then we have object mutation
we will come to that uh in the next
slides but this is also taken care of by
enzyme right now
and adjoin checkpointing so this has
been mentioned now several times by nora
chris and maybe also another talk that
seems to be really for climate models as
a time dependent problem being one of
the core issues
that you uh
iterate over time and then you compute
the adjoint in the reverse order and you
as billy said will oom
uh
very quickly and run out of memory
um
then sparse derivatives so how do you do
suppose you want to compute the full
sparse jacobian and then you want to
apply coloring compress your jacobian
and compute it in a
compressed way in order to
increase efficiency
um parallelism also their enzyme
has pretty much our back
non
non smooth computation is another topic
that we may look into
once we have real simulations running
so what has been done so far we focused
on checkpointing we have released the
check checkpointing package
checkpointing.jl
and we uh
what is in the id community this
state-of-the-art coloring library is
call pack and we ported that to
no we didn't port that to julia we
interfaced it to julia so you can use it
by just adding uh the callback package
and
it has the same interface as the one in
the sparsif tools
so let's get to adjoin checkpointing
i mean the issue has been explained
before you
have a time dependent problem you
iterate
forward
from
step zero to
step n or nine then you reverse and you
have to restore all these previously
computed
states
and this takes a lot of memory or
potentially takes a lot of memory
um
here we have
an example of cisco police where
binomial checkpointing was
successfully applied to compute really
long time
horizons
and so our goals is to support general
numerical simulation codes and make it
available to the julia community so that
they can use
checkpointing very easily in their
simulation codes our initial focus would
of course be the the climate simulation
codes that we have in this project
simple things should be simple so an
user who doesn't understand adjoint
checkpointing or even doesn't know about
adjoints should have should be it should
be very easy for him to just add
the decorator in the code and get the
checkpointing that he wants on the
hardware that he targets
then
we
use
julia
co-transformation macros so we transform
a loop into a check pointing loop
uh so that
you have a time dependent loop it then
becomes the uh a loop that computes the
forward and the reverse adjoined and
checkpointed we also want to support a
variety of checkpointing schemes so
there's not only the one checkpointing
scheme that
that is
that wins them all
so rules them all
there are
different kinds of checkpointing schemes
which have different um
advantages disadvantages depending on
which device you want to use and this
brings us then also to
the feature that we want to support that
we
can store checkpoints on multiple
devices maybe in gpu memory ram local
disk
um
so local disk on a
hpc cluster meaning on the node on the
system disk or even
checkpoint all the way back to archive
imagine if you have a run that goes on
for
a few days weeks
so what are all the checkpoint
checkpointing schemes about well
checkpointing schemes are about a
trade-off of
recomputation and
storage needs
in periodic checkpointing for instance
you see we
checkpoint that every second
time step
so we have one two three four five
checkpoints and then we do the
augmented forward run
and the reverse run and this is always
the same you always have the same number
of augmented forward and reverse runs
where the schemes differ are these
additional brown arrows that you get for
recomputing
until the point where you start the
augmented forward run
and binomial checkpointing has been
shown to be
optimal for i know this is not this is
binomial checkpointing yeah you see that
it only uses three checkpoints so you
preset a fixed number of checkpoints
that you want to use and it will spread
them in a way that is very efficient and
reduces the number of uh re-computations
um two observations that we made while
developing our checkpointing library
that we want to integrate in in the
codes
first one is that most juilliard tools
if not nearly all of them don't support
mutable objects so mutable arrays in the
in the most simple term
um but simulation codes are often
written that way so this looks very
fortunate this is also this is because
it is ported from a fortune code and you
just change
uh certain elements of an array but not
you you don't reallocate the entire
array to create a new one
so this does not work with most id tools
whereas
this code which creates a new array on
every change in the former array
this works fine
and the reason for that is that most ad
tools in julia were developed in times
where machine learning was the main
focus and in machine learning where you
just propagate through the layers and
then go reverse you indeed do not need
uh
mutation necessarily although maybe
today's research is also looking into
into into those issues and to implement
also checkpointing right into machine
learning
the second observation was that uh all
our codes that we use as an example so
these used by mature lulac
which we used as a
codes to
demonstrate enzyme and ocenanigans they
all use the same while loop where they
essentially start at the time
and they stop at the time which is
often unknown
um so the number of time steps are
unknown the time is known in uh
in seconds but you don't know how many
time step you're gonna need to reach
that simulation time
so all these codes you use a while loop
and all these codes go over a
struct so you have a domain a sim
or a fem model struct which has all
the
information that the model needs and
then you compute the next time step and
you get
the news
stayed out
so storing the entire structs
overestimates probably the entire state
you don't have to store everything like
for instance integer values
don't necessarily need to be stored
however this can be fully automated so
that's what we are aiming for that we
just take a struct we checkpointed
entire structs sequentialize it write it
out to disk or whatever and
store
the entire state
to make it as automated as possible
and
yeah and these are then our needs for
this project so it should be fully
automated as while loops with trucks uh
mutation should work and that's why we
are using an enzyme for most of this
because enzymes are this neat
abstraction
where it can differentiate structs so in
enzyme you don't have to have a variable
you just give it an uh
struct
struct output struct and it will
differentiate all the derivatives with
respect to everything uh in those
structs
and how are we going to embed uh adjoin
checkpointing in julian
so
checkpointing scheme
a checkpointing scheme is just another
function
and the loop that is being
differentiated is also just a function
so we can
incorporate all that into the chain
rules.jl package we can just define a
rule
for our checkpointing function
and
then
apply that in the in the differentiated
code
um
we have then a
function checkpoint struct where all
whether you have a for loop while loop
everything will be
mapped to this checkpoint struct
function
which has a primal struct and then an
adjoint struct which is
the terminology used from enzyme which
is the
shadow struct which has all the uh
adjoint information in it
and by defining a
chain rules.jl rule
we now have all that covered we every ad
tool that now uses
chainrules.jl will work with our
checkpointing library and we'll work
with all the schemes that are
implemented there
um so
how to install checkpointing.jl it's in
the official
release repo
package repo so you just add
checkpointing
it supports revolve which is shown to be
optimal under certain assumptions like
that writing and reading to memory uh
has has no cost
um
periodic checkpointing so at every
period you do a checkpoint this is for
instance useful if you write
asynchronously to disk
and you just want to write out as much
as possible so at every period you write
out
a state to a disk
and then it also has now uh online
revolve which
is used if you
do not know a priori how many time steps
you are going to do so this was very
important for us to support that very
early on
since all the three example codes
would would need this
then
in addition to doing the checkpointing
in memory so storing the entire struct
just in memory
we also added hdf5 support since that
seems to be the straightforward target
most large
computer system supports hdf5 most
numerical simulation codes work with
with the hdf5
and it has interestingly to me since i
have myself not really extensively used
it's uh support for multi-level caching
so you you you get certain features that
we want to have in in
checkpointing.jl you get uh for uh free
through through hdf5 like you can
pre-cache
certain
uh checkpoints into
ram
and load them from
from from this before they are used
um
so fully automated checkpointing is now
possible if the body
of the loop can be differentiated using
enzyme.jl and the outer
code outside of the loop can be
differentiated by any id tool that
supports chain
chain rules.jl and also assuming that
that tool then can differentiate that
code
if you manually manually write
storing and restore functions
you
we currently support all the id tools
so our tests currently run over
defractor enzyme reversitive and zygote
still i would qualify the entire code
still as fragile you probably run into
issues if you if you use it straight
away on your code and we are happy if
you submit issues on the on
on our github page
as an example
so these are the examples that we work
with not these nice coloring graphs of
oceans but 1d heat equation
and
we do 500 time steps
we have a boundary condition on the left
of 20 degrees
temperature whatever and 0 on the other
end
and then we
we initialize all the temperatures to
zero
and we let the simulation run for 500
time steps so before it reaches the
steady state and
then you get the nice gradient out here
on the right and this is implemented in
the example
um
so what you have to do then is
you have your struct heat where all the
information is stored so the previous
time step the next time step
current time time step
the size lambda and the number of time
steps so this is our struct that we have
defined
um you set the boundary conditions and
then you have you define your
checkpointing scheme and you have to
give it the struct type so heat in this
case and it will generate all this how
to store restore
and how to apply the chain rule rule and
all of that will be automatically
generated
uh and then you just can call a zygote
gradient of the sum of the heat
so here's the sum heat function
uh it has the advanced
function which advances the the the heat
equation one one time step and does that
for certain number of time steps and
then just reduces
all the heat so sums all the heat up
um
yeah and that is all that you have to do
so you add this checkpoint struct macro
you pass it the revolve
data structure that you have created for
this case
so this can also be flexible you can
have multiple checkpointing schemes and
then just pass here in whatever you want
to
die
dynamically at runtime
and
then
of course the
heat
object has to be passed too
so now zygote differentiates the outer
so the reduction effectively only and
enzyme differentiates the inner part of
of this loop
so the outlook
for fully automated differentiation we
need two things we need support of chain
rules for enzyme which was mentioned in
billy's talk so enzyme rules we are
working on on that so that is really
our next
focus
to get that
off the ground so that you can really
use whatever ad tool
uh wherever you uh like in inner loop
outer loop
um
so for
support of struct differentiation we
haven't gotten it off the ground yet so
that's why enzyme can only be used in
the inner in the inner loop
um
i try to implement it using zygot maybe
i'm doing also something wrong happy to
get comments on that
how to apply other id tools to
differentiate
how to make them differentiate structs
or what else is needed to achieve that
so a workaround or not really a
workaround but you can generate or
write custom store and restore functions
and then everything works with all 80
tools
uh in terms of application goal we want
to differentiate a simple mpi paralyzed
ice sheet model and show that it can run
on a on a large system and that we can
checkpoint the various devices at the
various levels
in the memory
hierarchy
um
yeah that that that is our uh
that is what we are looking as a main
outcome for
uh next year
then coloring um brief
look at coloring what we have done there
we release colpack.jl
which has a
[Music]
several graph coloring algorithms that
have shown in the ide community to be
really
pretty
i mean the best the state state of the
art
algorithms that are out there
we have exported the api to match the
the the one of spastiff tools so and you
and we use the binary builder to so that
you download automatically the binary of
call pack and you can just use this use
it straight away and play with call pack
there are certain features and
coloring tools that we still want to add
so they will come
when there is more interest into
coloring and why
did that stall a bit because we tested
it on our so we have power system
problems that we can apply this to which
are small unstructured graph problems
and we we observed that both positive
tools and call pack find the optimal
coloring so there's no real need for
using coldpack there however in these
applications here
we expect that if you have a sparse
jacobian problem where you want to
compute the full sparse jacobian
that call pack will be useful and we are
looking forward to uh to uh to this
and this is it thank you very much
i think you're muted
i have a newfound respect for tv
producers um so there's a question uh on
pigeonhole
would the 1d heat formulated in ocean
anigens and djus be a good setup for
testing integration that's possible and
it's possible in both tools
heat equation implemented in d juice or
shenanigans effectively
uh sorry i didn't fully understand the
question
so there is uh a 1d heat formulation in
ocean alligator would you say yes
uh we we didn't we we want to target an
ice sheet model
simply because that is what also the
applications uh site i mean the
application people want to target so the
heat equation here was really just
randomly picked because that's in
general an example that is often used in
the ad
community
right but
but presumably you could also do that
with ocean elegance
and yes
absolutely right okay
cool uh thank you so much again and i
will now hand over to chris rakakus i
will remove you first michelle
and add chris
oh chris is good to go okay uh
just a word about chris chris is the
co-pi of the julia lab at mit
uh the lead developer of the cyaml open
source software organization amongst us
many many qualifications over to your
chris yeah thank you very much so yeah i
wanted to give a brief status on uh
update of ad for cyaml applications in
julia right so we've seen a lot of this
lower level about what happens if people
are trying to write their own equation
solvers and such but you know when you
when you get to this higher level how
does this actually translate
to tools that are then you you know
built and used by by all everyone else
in the in the community right you know
how how has this dj for earth that
impacted everyone else um i want to
mention that there's a lot of major
contributors to the cymal sensitivity
whole ecosystem especially yingbo frank
avik and arno um and and so really you
know let me let me start by saying this
is not going to be a talk on siamel in
general if you want me to if you want to
see a talk all about you know the latest
in mixing models and data check out this
talk on youtube right that's uh there's
a standard talk i'll i give so i'll skip
over that for now um so let me let me
first start out with a lightning fast
motivation for why we want to do this
differentiable simulation right so
there's been a lot of other things that
have been come that have come up in this
you know world of you know things like
deep o nets and neural networks on the
outside with physics and form neural
networks so why has there been really a
push especially in the last year back
towards differential stimulation um i
think that this is very well highlighted
by a case on an ocean model so um we had
a case where we want to develop a you
know better parameterizations of this
ocean model so be able to find a
one-dimensional partial differential
equation that would capture the physics
of this three-dimensional pde just what
is the average heat flow in the up and
down range
it turns out that if you try to do this
in such a way where you say i'm going to
try to find a closure model and i want
to nudge my data around so that way i'm
looking at the derivatives i i find out
what you know what the derivative should
be i check out okay now i take my
derivative data the derivative data up
is like this you know but then i have a
residual if you then try to make this
this neural network directly match the
residual values uh you get something
that doesn't fit very well right
so and this is something that you can do
in any language you can do this with say
you know pi torch there's no
differential differentiation in the
simulator here if you take the fact that
you know that you're supposed to be
fitting derivatives you nudge all your
data so that way you have derivative
information you find out what the
the the uh residual is here and you
directly fit the data you know data set
to neural network right um but this does
not turn out to work out so well the
reason is because if you only try to
control the derivative of a process
that's evolving over time you will
naturally get a drift over time right so
what you want to do instead of
controlling derivatives only is you also
want to do integral control which
essentially corresponds to using the
solution to your uh to you to the model
with the neural networks embedded in it
you want to use that within your loss
function which naturally means that
you're in your simulators and your loss
function and so therefore you have to
differentiate it right so this is what
brings us to differentiable simulation
along with a lot of other things where
if you show if you look at say physics
and form neural networks versus a
differential simulation approach there's
about a ten thousand a hundred thousand
times difference where if you know
fourier neutral operators keep o nets
and physics and formula networks are
much slower than an optimized
differential simulator you can go check
out one of my other talks that describes
all all of that in detail but um so this
brings us to differentiating simulators
right but you know differentiable
differentiating simulators is all about
adjoints so why is automatic
differentiation important if we're just
using the adjoint method right
so uh how the
met you know there first of all there
isn't just one thing that's the adjoint
method right you you can mathematically
say that there's one adjoint method but
if you actually go and practice and come
up with implementations there's about
nine different adjoint methods or
there's about well you can actually come
up with a whole grid of 27 different uh
attribute methods given different
choices you can make but there's about
nine of those that are useful right now
the key about the these android methods
right when we talk about doing adjoint
methods you know you actually write down
an equation so you you if you're solving
an ode the derivative to an ode is
solving a different ode but that ode
that you're solving actually need has
you know you write that in and then you
solve that using your sulfur and so you
know julie's not the first to to offer
that so you know there's other large
scale sparse distributed library so
there's other libraries that have these
large-scale
stiff ode solvers developed for you know
partial differential equations so uh and
they also have adjoint techniques so you
know sundials can have adjoints um pet c
can have adjoints um and but you know
sundials have or in julia the julius iml
ones it has you know the adjoints with
checkpointing and sparse automatic
differentiation everything baked into it
so if you're using a sparse jacobian on
a huge pde you get that checkpointing
and everything automatically you get
that sparsity handling automatically but
the real big differentiator from from
the julia side to the classical c plus
libraries is that the automatic
differentiation is baked in and you know
in so even though
and the reason why this is important is
because calculating the derivative to an
ode is just just solving another od so
you you might assume that if you have an
a good ode solver then you can do this
effectively but the issue is that the
definition of that ode that you have to
solve actually has something in here
that is a vector jacobian product and
this vector jacobian product can it can
be calculated without forming the
jacobian only if you allow yourself
automatic differentiation in the way
this function is defined right so even
if you have a way to generate adjoints
that does not necessarily mean that you
have a way to to generate the android
equation in a way that is
efficient you have to have automatic
differentiation as part of that
code generation process in order to do
that and that's where julia really
shines um from from where the the
previous tools were
and now you know how how that is done
really matters uh we've we've now shown
for example that you know doing this
with enzyme is about two orders of
magnitude faster than a lot of the other
tools that we're using in julia before
so uh you know how do you how do how did
we take this and over the last year make
this package simul sensitivity and make
this truly automatic for users right so
this is all about the sensalik interface
if you and really the key is that if you
just stick a a solve right so if you
stick an ode solve inside of a loss
function and you say you calculate a
derivative
it will make use of automatic
differentiation overloads so that way
this will be done effectively so you you
know with forward mode you just stick
solve inside of a loss function you're
good uh with uh reverse mode you just
stick solve inside of a loss function
you're good so you know basically what
what you know there is no automatic
differentiation that you need to
directly think about with solve you know
the the way that this is done is that
when a
when a automatic differentiation library
sees the ode solve it will replace it
with adjoints automatically right so it
does this it does this change to create
this equation solve it and reverse
everything that's all done automatically
underneath the hood now
the key here is that you know you you
can actually choose right i mentioned
that there's many different adjoint
methods the way that the cyano uh the
cyml interface works is that there's a
keyword argument sensog which is only
captured when it's in an automatic
differentiation context and when you're
in an automatic differentiation context
it uses this to figure out uh this
sensal argument to figure out what kind
of of uh what kind of agility method
should i do right so what android method
should i do and what are the options for
that adjoint method so this is how you
would be able to turn on checkpointing
turn off checkpointing turn on you know
mixing and forward mode and all these
other options happen through the the
choice of sense out right
and now this has been around for for a
few years now but what we've really done
is we've expanded it to all sorts of
equation solvers so here for example is
a nonlinear problem solved with the
newton-raphson method and here you see
that hey we you know you just call solve
um and then there's a steady state
adjoint with the auto jack vac of enzyme
vjp so this is this means that you know
you want to use a newton method this
will run in newton's method and it will
use enzyme for the code that it
generates and i'll use you know the
android method on the outside for for
the for the actual solve it generates so
this is just done all automatically in
fact if you do not pass the sensal
algorithm it has a way to automatically
choose a default sense out in which case
it'll for this equation it'll actually
choose this this uh approach as the
default right so if you just stick you
know nonlinear solve or or differential
equations inside of a loss function and
you just call it say differentiate these
adjoint methods are done automatically
along with implicit function theorem all
the things that you mentioned that you
saw in the earlier talks are now
integrated into the tooling so that way
they're just done automatically those
those tricks are part of the library um
now how far have we gotten with this i
will say that not all of the equation
solver libraries uh handle this uh the
two to highlight our linear solve.jl and
optimization.jl are the two that are
notably need more adjunct support uh
though non-linear solvers uh the all the
differential equation solvers integrals
and a lot of the partial differential
equation interface uh does this that
does this integration automatically um
these next two bits are two of the
higher priority things in the cyano
universe right now
and what this really means then is that
you know the the cyan interface is
really growing in its interfaces which
i'm going to i have another talk at
julia con that will talk all about
linear solve.jl and so once that
handling for the attributes is on linear
soft dot jail then all of these
different solvers including sweet sparse
pardeso you know
as we're mixing making it do at pet c
and everything all of those are just
handled automatically by using the
linear solve.jl on their face right and
if you want to have make sure that
you're using the implicit function
theorem with all of the you know enzyme
and everything automatically well if you
use nonlinear solve then you have all
those adjoints automatically applied but
if you you know what is non-linear
solved well nonlinear solve has some of
its own methods but it also is minpac
sundials and allsolve.jl and steadystate
diffieq.jail for mixing in uh
pseudotransient methods so it basically
has you know
so basically there's these growing
interfaces where if you use this
interface not only do you have more
algorithms available and you have you
know and you have consistency among the
arguments and everything but you also
have you know a consistent way to be
able to choose how the adjoints are
generated through the sensog interface
and you have the optimality of the
adjoint implementations um this is then
done over the integral libraries with
integrals.jail right so all the ways of
doing cubature and all that and then
optimization.jl has a whole bunch of
optimization libraries this still needs
the the ad overload but that's coming
within the next month um
so so okay so that's
now let me get into the details of ejp
right so you just slap solvers around
they now are generating uh android
they're now using attract methods under
hood everywhere but what about this vjp
thing right so um the the centaught
interface the nice thing that's about it
is that optimized adjoints are enabled
by default this makes it so that way
wrap solver such as pet c cuba
sundials these are all supported without
end user intervention just by using the
cyaml interfaces
it's all part of the simol interface so
all of the you know all the tolerance
definitions are uniform all of the uh
options are uniform right we we use the
same naming between odes optimization
and nonlinear solving so that because we
have this uniformity um and many of the
highest performing solvers are actually
only available through the simol
interface you know because a lot of them
are developed as pure julia now the the
con of the science hog interface is that
it exists it requires that there exists
a vjp to handle your problem definition
i'll mention this in a sec and the issue
is that it only works with chain rules
on the outside chain rules id on the
outside which means that even if it's
using enzyme on the inside you need to
make sure that using zygote or defractor
on the outside at least for now
and you know so because so what do i
mean by this so the vjp is this
operation in here it's it's the
generation is the code generation step
of what code are you going to put into
that adjoint solve right it doesn't
matter if it's an ode you solve another
ode if it's a nonlinear solve you solve
a nonlinear solve but all equation types
always have a vector jacobian product in
the equation that you generate and so
there's always this question of how
should i use reverse mode on my
differentiation in that code generation
process um
and
what we do is you know we have this
whole sense out interface so that way
you can then say oh with this method i
want to use the sensitivity algorithm
and for sensitivity algorithms you can
choose whether i want to you you know
which vjp you want to use and we don't
supply it it does something by default
what it does is is a poly algorithm so
for example it knows that for a given
solver class there's a cutoff where if
the solver you know if you're solving a
nonlinear system and it's less than 50
parameters then you do use forward mode
automatic differentiation uh for the vjp
right so you construct the jacobian and
transpose it because that's actually
faster you can see your benchmarks on
that but if you're above that level then
what it'll do is it'll try to use enzyme
if it can't use enzyme then it'll use
reverse diff with tape compilation if it
can prove that you don't have branches
inside of your code how does it prove
that it doesn't have branches inside of
your code it uses cassette to actually
look at your julia code try to find any
branches and it it's conservative so if
it finds anything that it doesn't
understand or if it finds a branch then
it says they can't do this um if it
can't do that then it uses no tape
compilation right so there's a very
extensive poly algorithm for house and
choosing what
ad mechanism to use in this code
generation but this is all but done by
default you you can directly choose
which algorithm you want to use but in
these days it's usually best for users
just to leave it alone and let the poly
algorithm do its do its trick um because
there's there's a whole bunch of
different ways that the vjp can be done
which makes different performance
support and and other limitations um
now the the current difficulty with that
you can run into is the fact that
there's no vjp that
kind of covers all of the cases so so
where we are right now
is that enzyme is going to be default um
which means that it's tried first right
so we if we see that your code is you
know trying to mutate then what we'll do
you know so we do a code inspection if
we see that it's trying to mutate we say
aha we're going to try enzyme on here
that's that's our default right we
always try to for all these hydrogens
that we generate for sense logs and uh
with integrals with uh odes with
nonlinear solve we try enzyme first but
uh and if you've already written
actually really good code so if you've
written non-allocating type stable pde
codes you get really fantastic code
right you get code that is really fast
uh greatly out performance tools like
jax as as uh as um billy mentioned in
the enzyme talk right there's it's not
even close like this is very very very
good performance
and the nice thing too is that enzyme if
it can't differentiate something it just
always throws you hair it's a very safe
uh thing now the difficulty with it
right now that some of you may have run
into is that if enzyme is tried every
once in a while it throws errors at the
lovm level that are not caught at the
julia level which to a julia user will
look like a segfault because that can
kill your julia rebel
and so when we do this try-catch
approach of being like hey can enzymes
do this every once in a while it
actually causes julia to fail um that's
why you might see a segfault every once
in a while and please open up an issue
really all that this requires is it
requires us to find the different cases
that enzyme isn't throwing it as a julia
level heir and then one by one just make
sure that all those certain jewelry are
level errors if that's the case then you
know this this algorithm of you know try
to try enzyme then then try something
else you know with these different
fallbacks then it works out the current
difficulty here is that sometimes when
it tries this it hits this this air that
is not able to recover from and so if we
help enzyme find what all those pieces
are then this this uh this vjp choice
becomes a lot more robust um
now the other thing is that enzyme still
has limited support for julia's runtime
which means that it's it's support for
uh dynamic dispatches like typed in
stabilities and carb garbage collection
is still kind of uh small um that is
definitely growing over time but for
right now what we kind of you know the
reason why
this this this whole system is set up is
really because those cases aren't caught
well by enzyme and so sometimes we need
to move to reverse death or or zygote to
be able to handle those cases um so the
tl dr with it is if you've written like
a very fast non-allocating pde code uh
it's
you know it will pretty much always
automatically choose enzyme for you yeah
the differentiation that you get is
really amazing um the dif the bad part
is that if you've written a bad code so
one that is you know type unstable or or
causing a lot of allocations then uh
then you it won't hit enzyme and then
you have less performance and you know
you have other difficulties um this
would the reason why this kind of shows
up as a real issue and that you see a
lot of issues on discourse is that well
the people who tend to write really
really good codes tend to be the people
who also know how to debug things well
which means that we're in this kind of
bad situation where the people who
the people who uh you know
are not as good at writing like really
good performant code are also the ones
that get the the ad issues uh that they
have to post a discourse to kind of
figure out oh why does this vjp issue
show up um also code that mixes ml kind
of has some of these difficulties as
well in certain cases so this is this is
really what we're working on we're
working with the enzyme developers to
kind of showcase all the different cases
where vjps generally fail and kind of
work on those over time um but really
what we're what we're ending up with is
a composable infrastructure where you
know we have tools for generating for
for pdes that generate odes and you know
the od solvers hit the optimization.jl
and they use nonlinear solve and linear
solve under the hood which all have the
right adjoints to find and so everything
really just builds up itself to be able
to build you know this this composable
system where everything has adjoints
already defined on it as long as it's
using these higher level interfaces of
cyanol um and with that we see a whole
lot of performance benefits that have
come
even especially within the last year
we've seen a lot
thanks to
integrating enzyme is now one of the
default choices throughout the ecosystem
so yeah thank you very much
thanks chris for a great talk
i'm not seeing questions yet on
pigeonhole or on youtube but i do want
to ask are other than branching
um
type instabilities and allocations are
you is there anything else that a sort
of someone trying to
differentiate uh using enzyme should
watch out for and is this documented
somewhere as they get started with
differentiating codes through enzyme
yeah i mean so i will say that you know
when you're
i will say that these days i uh for the
most part you just shouldn't choose a
vector jacobian product algorithm just
kind of let that be under the hood so
you know for for the most part you know
just just let it do its thing but if you
want to help out the development right
then you can directly choose a bjp
algorithm and then if you if you do that
directly then you might see like hey you
know this would have failed and then it
would have gone to a slower method um
and the reason why it's gone to this
lower method normally comes down to some
garbage collection dynamic dispatch or
something i i guess the thing that i
missed was a
support for for linear algebra missing
right you know some i think that map
moles are handled now but if you have
say an lu factorization inside of your
ode solve or an lu factorization instead
of the right hand side of your of your
newton method right um those are the
things that can make uh enzyme uh not
work and then it will fall back to
reverse diff and you might take a
performance hit or something um
yeah
right
well um
well with that thank you chris and i
want to take the opportunity to thank uh
all the speakers and the audience for
participating
and uh thank you to the julia organizers
as well i declare the mini symposium to
be over we'll be happy to receive
questions on pigeonhole and answer them
as
in the future as well thank you everyone
bye enjoy the rest of your day